[Musique]
Guillaumeis Guillaumeis bonsoir. Oui,
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Oui, je m'appelle Guillaume Muris mais
ça vous venez de le dire. Je suis
comment on pourrait dire ? fabricant de
blagues et écrivailleurs de trucs
notamment des romans
et aussi musicien.
Alors, j'irai peut-être pas tout de
suite sur ce terrain là. Disons que oui,
j'ai créé un groupe de musique, le
premier groupe de rock macronistes de
l'histoire, euh de la musique, du monde.
Voilà, avec des amis, des vrais
musiciens pour le coup. C'est j'en ai
fait un spectacle musical assez
déconnant dont je suis assez content.
Mais voilà, malheureusement la tournée
comme vous le savez pour l'instant
reporter. On va Oui. Le Covid difficile.
Oui, parce qu'il y a un virus là. Vous
avez suivi ce truc
un petit peu.
Ouais. Voilà.
On est un peu à cheval sur les précoles
de les protocoles de santé comme tu peux
le voir.
Oui oui oui. D'ailleurs, il a un masque
hein. Je dis voilà
dans les commentaires. C'est pour la
peine de mettre. Ouais. D'accord.
Mais ils ont changé attention carte sur
table, ils ont changé de locau. Il y a
de la tune Feriew.
La dernière fois qu'ils m'ont reçu,
c'était dans un hangar
dans une cave.
Ouais, dans une cave. Ils étaient là un
peu en mode hackur ninja tout ça. Et
maintenant les beaux quartiers de Paris.
Non non franchement, il y a du pognon.
Je sais pas qui est derrière, je vais
enquéter un petit peu.
On est en colocation d'ailleurs. On se
concentre un peu.
Ouais, pardon.
On est au 21e siècle. Notre société est
en train de se prendre une énorme
pandémie dans la tête. Économiquement
parlant, c'est difficile. Est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dresser votre propre
constat ? La perception de la France au
21e siècle.
Comme ça ? Perception de la France au
21e siècle. Direct. Combien de temps ?
J'ai combien de temps ?
Euh 2h minimum.
OK, on est bon. Euh et ben je pense que
c'est une bonne opportunité. Moi je
pense que c'est une bonne opportunité de
de ralentir le mouvement puisque de
toute façon on savait qu'on allait dans
le mur et on savait qu'on y allait à
toute vitesse. Euh là je pense que c'est
une opportunité de de de se calmer et de
réfléchir à justement tu parlais de la
crise économique de qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? Qu'est-ce que c'est exactement
l'économie ? Est-ce que c'est une course
à la richesse personnelle ou une course
à la redistribution ? Je pense que là
tout le monde a bien compris que l'enjeu
c'était plutôt la redistribution. Donc
c'est l'occase. Est-ce que l'humanité en
règle générale est et
là à ce moment précis va saisir
l'occasion ? Je sais pas, je suis assez
nul en prédiction.
Euh mais j'espère en tout cas. Ouais, de
tout cœur. Ouais.
Comment avec ton avec ton boulot
déjà un, tu fais comment pour t'informer
? Comment tu fais pour résister à toutes
ces mauvaises nouvelles ? Comment tu
fais
pour ensuite le mettre en humour ? Bah,
c'est la réponse dans la question. Euh
comment je fais pour résister au aux
mauvaises nouvelles ? Je je prends de la
distance avec l'humour. L'humour, ça
permet de prendre directement du recul
par rapport au réel et puis de pouvoir
en déconner. Je pense que c'est plutôt
un mode de défense. Là, on attaque
direct dans la psychanalyse, mais non,
mais je crois qu'il y a quand même un
peu de vrai là-dedans. Euh donc quand je
vois une une actu,
je je assez rapidement une idée de
blague ou de décalage ou euh ou une
manière d'en d'en rire plutôt que que de
la sidération. Mais ça c'est un truc que
j'ai depuis gamin. Donc c'est plutôt ça
vient plutôt de l'éducation, je pense.
Et puis que je développe. Je pensais pas
en faire un métier un jour, ça c'est sûr
et certain.
Euh mais aujourd'hui, j'ai du bol de
pouvoir gagner ma vie en en faisant ça
et en me protégeant de la réalité et euh
et en plus avec une audience pas mal via
la Radio France quoi.
Tu t'es fait harceler quand tu étais
gamin ?
Non, pas du tout. Non non. J'ai une
enfance assez heureuse moi. À la
campagne, paumée dans la campagne
profonde mais assez cool. Non, mais
quand tu as l'humour, quand tu es gamin,
euh ça permet voilà, ça permet de mettre
à distance les autres aussi, la réalité
mais aussi les autres. Donc c'est pas
c'est pas mal. Ouais. Moi je vois pas
l'humour comme une arme mais comme une
comme une défense. Ouais.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu peux comprendre
que les gens que tu railles, ils
prennent ça comme une attaque ?
Alors pour être tout à fait précis, je
ne raille pas les gens. D'ailleurs, je
j'ai refusé de faire ce que je fais à la
radio, à la télévision parce que c'est
pas les gens qui m'intéressent. C'est
pas madame Michou qui va acheter sa
baguette de pain et qui dit "Il y a trop
de noir en France". C'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse. J'ai pas envie que le
lendemain elle se fasse emmerder dans la
rue par des gens qui disent "On vous a
vu, vous avez dit de la merde et
cetera." Par contre, c'est les discours
qui m'intéressent. Donc moi, ce que je
vais chercher avec mon petit micro et
mes petites blagounettes quand je vais
faire tel ou tel marché ou j'en sais
rien, tel ou tel cololloque, c'est
plutôt les discours. Et dans les
discours, les contradictions, les
incohérences, les failles de
raisonnement, l'absurdité, ça tout ça ça
m'intéresse et dès que je chope quelque
chose de cet ordre-là, je creuse, je
rebondis. Ça ça m'amuse beaucoup mais je
raille pas les gens. Je cite d'ailleurs
jamais le nom des gens déjà parce que je
les connais pas. Sauf les gens qui ont
responsabilité à savoir les élus bien
sûr parce que ils ont des comptes à nous
rendre et les pores-paroles. Ça m'est
arrivé de faire le lobby du plastique
par exemple des polymères
et du pétrole aussi.
Je sais plus comment ça s'appelle mais
voilà. Enfin donc là je citais le nom de
la personne puisque ça avait un intérêt
quoi. Mais sinon non c'est plutôt les
discours moi que les gens. Quel
Quel est le discours politique que tu
trouves le plus incohérent en ce moment
?
Bah le le
libéralisme libéralisme économique je
dirais. Je sais pas parce que tout le
monde tout le monde a l'air de de
s'entendre pour dire que de toute façon
c'est c'est c'est c'est pas viable
à échelle planétaire. C'est pas viable
quoi. Donc
le CAC 40 est à 6000 points, tout va
bien.
Non mais ça c'est des tu vois c'est des
chiffres. Le CAC 40 est à 6000 points.
S'il y a plus d'oxygène pour respirer à
moment donné sur la planète euh le CAC
40 il sera peut-être à 250000 points
mais on s'en fout. Donc
c'est ça qui me rend le plus le plus
dingo mais qui rend le plus dingo tout
le monde, c'est de savoir pertinemment
que de toute façon c'est un modèle qui
est pas pérenne et de pas réussir à le
stopper, ça serait l'idéal mais même de
la ralentir
ça ça rend parce que si tu discutes avec
n'importe qui et c'est c'est que c'est
ce que je fais tous les jours, tout le
monde va te dire bah oui oui on peut pas
continuer cette course effrainée vers la
la croissance et ce genre de truc Et
pourtant
ça continue quand même quoi. Tout le
monde sait qu'on va dans le mur mais on
y va quand même. C'est plutôt ça qui me
qui me rend dingo. Ouais.
Tu as essayé de te mettre à la place de
de nos dirigeants ou de ceux sur le
système financier qui évoluent tous les
jours avec
des chiffres avec 90. Est-ce que tu t'es
mis est-ce que tu t'es mis à leur place
? Tu t'es mis dans leur tête ? Est-ce
que tu te dis pas voilà pourquoi ils
continuent ? Peut-être qu'ils sont en
train de nous accorder du temps et de la
sérénité.
Non, je me mets pas. Enfin oui, je me
mets à leur place parce que c'est des
êtres humains et je crois que je suis un
être humain. Donc eux aussi sont pris
dans un truc de déterminisme. Bah
j'imagine que quand tu quand tu vis à
l'aise avec plein de poogons, tu es pas
le mieux placé pour dire "Bon bah ouais,
non mais en fait il y en a qui le font
mais bon c'est extrêmement rare. Tu es
pas le mieux placé pour dire bon bah on
arrête les conneries, on redistribue."
Enfin ça paraît logique.
Ça c'est pour l'aspect financier, pour
l'aspect politique.
Je crois même que c'est plus grave que
ça. la structure qui fait que ce sont
ces gens-là qui se retrouvent à ces
postes là. Moi, j'en veux quasiment pas
au députés parce que quand tu es député
ou même Macron quoi, on dit Macron
d'émission, c'est pas tant le problème
si c'est pour remplacer par quelqu'un
d'autre, c'est c'est ça ça sera la la
même problématique. C'est-à-dire que je
crois en tout cas quand tu t'engages en
politique, queles que soient les idées
que tu as, tu as des convictions, tu as
la jeunesse qui va, tu as la fougue, tu
es militant de base, tu vas sur les
marchés, machin tout ça. Si tu commences
à être sur un un poste éligible sur un
une place pardon éligible sur une liste
et qu'on dit bah tu sais si tu veux
gagner de trois places peut-être ton
discours là il est un peu trop chelou
atténue un peu ça tu commences à faire
des compromis. C'est ça que je veux
dire. Plus tu vas monter plus tu vas
faire de compromis. Donc
structurellement tous ceux qui restent
au plus haut niveau, ce sont les gens
qui font qui ont fait le plus de
compromis. Donc forcément
compromis ou avaler des coups d'œuvres.
Bah c'est pareil pour moi. Oui oui. Bah
oui pour être à ces postes là la
structure fait que bah tu as dû avaler
des couleuvres si tu veux si tu aimes
bien filer la métaphore animalière. Donc
j'en veux une fois de plus ça rejoint un
peu ta question d'avant. J'en veux pas
aux gens c'est pas tel député qui est
con. C'est la structure qui fait que
permet à ces gens-là d'être à ces postes
de décision importants. Donc oui si tu
veux je me mets à leur place.
Et quand on quand tu es député,
j'imagine tu rentres dans ta famille
manger à Noël, enfin je sais pas, il y a
il y a il y a un statut social qui est
pas dégueu. Donc qu'est-ce que tu vas du
jour en main ? Tu vas pas dire "Ah non
mais en fait ouais non je fais de la
merde." Mais ça te met dans des
positions de dissonance cognitive
terrible quoi. Tuas des députés, je
discutais avec quelques députés, des
fois ils te disent
et une députée dont je terra le nom qui
m'a dit qui m'a dit "J'aime bien Édouard
Louis."
Je dis bah Édouard Louis, il a quand
même écrit un bouquin pour dire Macron a
tué mon père. Donc comment tu peux voter
la baisse des APL le matin et lire un
livre d'Edouard Louis l'après-midi en me
disant "Ouais, pas mal." Enfin c'est Tu
vois, c'est là où je me dis c'est c'est
c'est dingot en fait.
Pardon pour cette analyse politique.
C'est dingo. Wou, c'est puissant hein.
On vit dans un
Non mais tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est vraiment la c'est la structure
qu'il faut changer. Alors le problème et
après je te laisserai poser ta question,
le problème c'est que pour changer cette
structure faut la hacker et donc va
falloir pour changer la 5e République,
faut être élu donc va falloir passer le
casting.
C'est très intéressant ce que tu dis.
Merci.
Je vais boire un coup tellement
Alors bois un coup comme ça parler.
Euh quand tu entends quand tu tu dis il
faut la hacker, il faut la hacker,
c'est-à-dire il faut s'introduire
d'une façon furtive, c'est-à-dire
devenir l'eau,
se se camoufler au sein de ce nid de
requin.
Ouais.
Pour ensuite prendre le pouvoir où il
faut il faut y aller en opposition,
c'est-à-dire de force
les casser de force. Bah la révolution
ou la réforme quoi, c'est ça l'éternel
débat.
Le cheval de 3 ou le brut de force.
Je j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis définitif
sur la question. Je crains que le cheval
de 3 la structure est trop forte et
finit par te bouffer parce que c'est
c'est voilà, c'est là depuis des années,
c'est costaud,
c'est Ouais. Ouais. un peu un peu huge
comme on dirait. Et et l'aspect
révolutionnaire
est assez facilement réprimable. Donc
non, j'ai pas la solution. Tu imagines
bien que d'ailleurs si j'avais la
solution, bon j'allais dire je serai pas
là si je serai là quand même mais je te
la dirai direct. Je dirais on fait pas
les conneries là, la solution c'est ça
et on y va. Donc je sais pas.
Par exemple, si tu devais, imagine-toi
dans une autre réalité et je prends ma
baguette magique, je te mets
présidential, tu as toutes tes
signatures, tout va bien. Ta campagne,
tu la finances comment ? Bah ouais,
c'est ça. On va toujours rebondir sur
les mêmes trucs. Bah bon, l'idéal,
voilà, pour jouer le jeu, je la
financerai le plus horizontalement
possible avec des financements
participatifs. Euh, tu mets une limite,
alors là, elle est à 7500, je crois. Tu
mets une limite à 2000 balles. Euh
voilà, tu as des tu tu essayes de gérer
ça avec le plus de contrôle possible, tu
la rends complètement transparente.
Enfin, il y a des outils quand même qui
peuvent exister. Donc ça c'est une
question Oui, c'est une question de
volonté. Je dirais pour faire l'exercice
de pensée que tu me proposes, je dirais
quelque chose comme ça. Ouais. Un
cas concret, imagine-toi que tu as un
luxembourgeois qui a
une prise de conscience, il se rend
compte que
tous les luxembourgeois sont pas les
milliardaires. Attention, je vois que tu
fais les amalgames.
Bien entendu, tous les luxembourgeois ne
sont pas milliardaires et tous les
milliardaires ne sont pas
luxembourgeois.
Et imagine-toi que de l'argent venant du
Luxembourg proposé pour financer ta
campagne.
Ben, je pense que tu peux pas. Enfin,
non. Non mais là, tu me proposes un
exercice de pensée qui est très facile
pour moi parce que je suis pas dans la
situation. Donc moi, je vais te faire le
chevalier blanc. Je vais te dire bah
non, évidemment je ne l'accepte pas. De
toute façon, si c'est transparent, tout
le monde le saura. Donc de la seule
solution, c'est la transparence
là-dedans. Si c'est transparent, à ce
moment-là, tout le monde va te enfin
dans l'instant où tu acceptes, tout le
monde va te dire "Ah bah super,
tu es pas un peu fleur bleu pour aller
nager avec les requins ?"
Mais moi, je vais est-ce que je vais
nager avec les requins ? Non.
Ou alors qui où est-ce que les requins
sont vraiment Si ça se trouve, on s'en
fait toute une montagne de ces requins.
Non, je sais que tu les c'est peut-être
en les considérant comme des requins
qu'on en fait des des des choses
dangereuses.
Faut jamais
Ça se trouve c'est juste des nuls hein.
Tu as déjà pensé à ça ?
Incompétent.
Ouais. Moi, c'est mon gros cheval de
bataille, poneet de bataille comme
dirait mon ami Juliette Tarna. Je me dis
toujours où commence l'incompétence et
où termine le cynisme. J'ai l'impression
et là je vais te faire vraiment la
sociologie de de base, j'ai l'impression
pour avoir vraiment été à l'Assemblée
nationale, salle des quatre colonnes,
interrogé les députés
euh que avant il y avait une espèce de
vieille droite chirakienne, enfin RPR
tout ça, Filloniste, tout ça qui était
pas dupe. Et quand il répondait à mes
questions, je sentais qu'il y avait un
truc euh ouais, non mais je te dis ça
mais évidemment bien sûr, on s'en fout,
viens, on va boire une bière quoi. Donc
je sentais du cynisme et je avec les
macronistes, je ressens plus de de la
bêtise
des je sens parfois convaincu dire non
non supprimer l'ISF c'est excellent mais
mais tu peux pas le tu vois dans ma tête
je fais mais non enfin à la limite
trouve-moi une formule pour me dire que
oui ils disent non ça va relancer
l'économie comme ça les riches ils vont
pas quitterf tout l'éternel truc quoi
élément de langage mais ils sont
convaincus je dis [__] et je trouve ça
plus dangereux moi.
Voilà, c'était mon analyse
parce que parce qu'ils se rendent pas
compte.
Ah ouais, parce que quand
tu vois le truc des APL et Louis, je me
dis bah tu bah sans déconner, enfin je
suis pas
je suis pas plus intelligent que la
moyenne he mais là il me semble qu'il y
a il y a un problème. Tu tu ne peux pas
faire ça en fait dans ta vie.
Prochaines élections tu vas voter quoi ?
J'en sais rien qui se présente.
Mélenchon Montbourg.
Honnêtement, j'en sais rien. Je peux te
faire la langue de bois, mais j'en sais
rien du tout.
Si si tu avais une question à poser à
Emmanuel Macron, tu lui poserais quoi
comme question ?
Est-ce que tu es heureux ?
C'est quoi être heureux ?
Bah, est-ce que tu es épanoui ? Est-ce
que tu te sens à ta place ? Est-ce que
tu te dis qu'après ton passage, le monde
il va être un peu moins dégueulasse que
l'ingénieur du son, il dit "Baisse un
peu ta fermeture éclair parce que
pardon !"
Eh, ingénieur du son.
Voilà.
Pardon.
Euh ouais ouais, je lui demanderai ça.
Je dirais est-ce que ça va toi ?
Et après j'ai si il me dit ouais pas de
problème pourquoi
tu arrives à dormir ?
Ouais voilà il dira je dors assez peu.
Je alors allez
la gestion de la crise du Covid pour un
humoriste, ça doit être caviar non ?
Ouais ouais ouais ben ouais non c'est
ces caviar ils arrivent pas à dire
qu'ils savent pas. Ils arrivent pas à
dire "Non ben désolé, de toute façon
c'est la merde.
Tout sais c'est encore ça rejoint ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure.
C'est-à-dire que tout le monde voit bien
que c'est la merde. De toute façon, les
scientifiques se contredisent, il y a
des variants qui déboulent, on ne sait
où. Donc Castex, il arriverait en disant
"Non mais bon, on fait ce qu'on peut,
c'est foireux mais on peut pas faire
autrement. On pense que c'est la
meilleure solution. C'est ça. Au lieu de
faire les quék en disant "Non, non mais
c'est bon, on gère, vous inquiétez pas,
tout va bien." Je pense que ça passerait
mieux parce que tout le monde est
capable de comprendre que de toute
façon, on
a vigue à vu. Alors, tu vois le coup des
masques, tu enfin je dis à quel moment
tu vas penser que
ça va convaincre l'opinion publique ?
surtout pour dire l'inverse, enfin tout
ce qu'on a vu quoi.
Je pense qu'avant il savait mieux
prendre les gens pour des cons.
Maintenant ça se voit. Mais même Macron
dans sa manière de parler aux gens, il
leur dit "Salut." Bah dison tu es con.
Non non attends mais on peut pas parler
comme ça aux gens. Vous avez pas de
boulot ? Bah si il y en a là-bas. Non
non non
les conseillers il font non non tu peux
pas parler aux gens comme ça tu vas te
faire taper quoi. Donc j'ai l'impression
que ouais j'ai cette impression-là
qu'avant il y avait euh voilà du un peu
plus de cynisme. Alors bon je défends
pas le cynisme évidemment on a bien
compris mais euh il y a quelque chose
qui passait mieux. C'est pour ça que les
gens alors je suis pas porte-parole des
gens ni sociologue tout ça mais j'ai
l'impression que Chirak a eu cette bonne
image parce que il y mettait de il y
mettait de l'humain quoi. Il buvait une
bière avec les gens et sincèrement ça
lui plaisait.
Je pense que voilà, tu peux je pense que
tu peux mentir aux gens mais il faut
être sympa.
Je devrais faire conseiller un peu
mais Foi en général il termine comme ça
hein les journalistes il terminent comme
moi je suis pas journaliste. N'oublie
pas hein la charte de Munique et tout là
je sais que c'était
des petites marottes. Non non moi je
suis humoriste. Ça me va très bien. J'ai
pas de carte de presse.
J'ai un graphiste qui qui m'a envoyé euh
son travail sur la chair de Munique et
et elle est dans mes toilettes donc tu
es obligé de la voir et de la lire
tous les jours. Tu la lis
tous les jours.
C'est bien.
Et revenons à nos moutons. Est-ce que
est-ce que le refus d' vue de
ce ce refus de de reconnaître son
impuissance, c'est fait pourquoi ? C'est
fait pour couvrir toute une strate de
fonctionnaires qui n'ont servi
strictement à rien depuis des décennies.
Le fait d'engager des cabinets privés,
c'est c'est fait pour quoi ? Pour
courtcircuiter ces strates
de réel état qui contrôle notre
impuissance. Est-ce que Est-ce que quand
tu vois ça, ça t'inspire quelques
petites blagues ce refus de d'aveu
d'impuissance ?
Mais moi, je vois que de la peur
là-dedans. Je vois que des des gens qui
flippent déjà parce que ils ont peur de
l'opinion publique. Euh il est suite aux
gilets jaunes et cetera. Enfin, ça leur
a quand même mis un gros gros coup he
parce que je pense même que c'est la
première fois qu'ils ont eu peur de se
faire péter la gueule physiquement.
Alors, je sais pas si c'est vrai
l'histoire de l'hélico de Macron qui
était prêt et tout. Bon bref, mais en
tout cas, ils ont ressenti le danger
physique
et à mon avis, comme ils ont fait les
grandes écoles et tout, c'est un truc
qu'ils ont jamais vraiment ressenti dans
leur vie, quoi. Donc je je vois ça
plutôt comme de la peur de se dire "Bon,
on va encore s'en prendre plein la
gueule euh on va faire les mecs euh qui
gèrent la situation." Et nous
évidemment, euh tu me demandais l'aspect
comique, bah là tu vois que le ridicule
quoi. Il y a rien de plus ridicule que
quelqu'un qui se prend au sérieux en
disant "Vous inquiétez pas, je gère." et
qui perd son pantalon quoi. C'est c'est
la base de l'humour. la peau de banane,
je vais à un endroit à un autre de
manière très sûre de moi, je glisse sur
une peau de banane. Rire. Bon, on est
vraiment au racines de la de la
blagounette. Donc là, on est dans une
tragie comédie parce que bon bah
évidemment il y a des morts et c'est
terrible quoi. Mais avec des mecs qui
disent les mecs et des nanas d'ailleurs
que je sois un peu plus inclussif mais
qui disent "Vous inquiétez pas tout est
sous contrôle et derrière tu as tout qui
crame, des mecs qui partent en courant
des CRS qui bornent des gens enfin et et
tout et tout le monde le voit. C'est pas
il faut pas être journaliste
d'investigation, c'est au 20h tous les
jours n'importe quel réseau social.
le le le dit enfin voilà c'est la
situation est connue
dans le showbiz parce que tu es un peu
du showbiz.
Je suis du showbiz. Ouais. Ouais, j'ai
ma carte. Non, pas du tout. Mais vas-y,
dis-moi quand même peut-être je vais
pouvoir te répondre.
Montre tes chaussures. Ils vont
comprendre pourquoi.
C'est les chaussures. Ah ouais, es sont
trouvées.
Non, la semelle c'est bien. C'est bien.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur la schemelle ?
Et ben elle est usée comme il faut. Tu
n'es pas la face fashion toi. Tu es tu
es la lion. Comme ça que tu traques. Les
Exactement.
C'est chaussures véganes.
Et comment ? Comment dans le showbiz
ça discute autour des gilets jaunes ?
Comment quand ils perçoivent ça ? Ils en
discutent avec toi ou tu fais partie
d'une case à part ? Non,
un petit peu le trouble le le celui qui
est un peu perturbant perturbateur
turbulent
mais je je sais même pas si ça existe
encore le choix biz. J'en sais rien.
Non. Bah en tout cas si ça existe, j'y
suis pas. Non mais on peut imaginer les
soirées enfin je sais pas. Pour moi, ça
me rappelle euh Drucker Guiluxe, j'étais
peut-être un peu trop un peu trop jeune
à l'époque, mais oui, ça me rappelle
Drucker, Jean-Pierre Fouco,
l'entreo du vétaria. Euh je c je je
crois je sais pas si ça existe encore.
Je crois pas. Je pense pas. Alors ce
qu'il pensent des gilets jaunes et puis
déjà les gilets jaunes, c'est compliqué
hein parce que les gilets jaunes, ça
veut un peu rien dire. Enfin, ça veut
tout et rien dire. tu mets ce que tu
veux dedans. Des revendications des
gilets jaunes, ce serait plus Et ben
écoute, je n'en sais rien. Il y a eu des
trucs rigolos quand même. Mais Franck
Dubos que qui a dit "Ouais, je suis avec
vous." Non, si qu'est-ce qu'il faut que
je dise ? s'il vous plaît, laissez-moi
faire des spectacles. Donc, tu sens que
Oui, il y en a qui sont un peu sur des
œufs. Ouais, bien sûr. Ouais, mais après
en règle générale, j'en sais rien. Ils
sont un peu sur des œufs. Tu parlais de
Franck Dubosque, tu as écrit un bouquin
euh qui qui décrit la vie de du bouffon
du roi Françoiser.
Ouais. Et euh quand le pouvoir se tend,
ça devient de plus en plus difficile à à
gagner sa kigne, son croûon de pain.
Est-ce que est-ce que les humoristes,
ils se ils se font castrer en ce moment
?
Mais c'est pareil, c'est les questions
trop vastes. Les humoristes, qu'est-ce
que qui est qui où ? Moi, je peux te
parler de ma situation, je peux te
parler alors je vais je vais faire je
vais refaire cette question. Non non, ma
situation en tout cas est plutôt
confortable puisque Radio France euh on
n' pas d'actionnaire principal à part
vous et euh et il y a très peu de
publicité donc on n' pas la pression des
annonceurs et moi j'ai aucun souci à
pouvoir on est en direct en plus donc
j'ai aucun souci à pouvoir dire ce que
je veux de la manière dont je le veux.
Moi j'ai vraiment voilà à la place
rêver. Je peux pas je peux pas rêver
mieux
mais on voit des choses dans les médias
privés. Bah si on veut reprendre un
exemple récent, Sébastien Tohen euh
voilà qui se fait virer par Boloré mais
c'est intéressant pas pour faire de la
pub pour mon bouquin mais par rapport au
du coup je vais en faire quand les gens
disent ça ça veut dire qu'il vont en
faire. Non non mais je veux dire le le
ce qui est le pouvoir donc mon bouquin
parle des bouffons de de cours donc
bouffon du roi.
Le pouvoir aujourd'hui le roi c'est
quasiment plus Macron. Le pouvoir c'est
le pouvoir économique. Voilà Boloré est
plus puissant que Macron. Donc euh les
humoristes ont plutôt à craindre du
pouvoir économique et on le voit voilà
quand tu as des des Sébastiens Toyen qui
se font virer pour une blague pour un
sketch euh par euh par euh le roi quoi,
le fait du du pouvoir qui te dégage
comme ça en en une fraction de seconde
plutôt à craindre de ce côté-là.
Aujourd'hui, le roi c'est le marché
quoi, si je vous lais résumer.
Donc c'est plus ça qui est inquiétant.
Pour mon cas personnel, j'ai de la
chance d'être là où je suis. D'ailleurs,
je me demande si je pourrais faire ce
que je fais aujourd'hui ailleurs. Euh,
je crois pas. Je crois pas parce que si
je fais un truc euh au salon du gaz et
que je vais interroger euh Total et que
on me dit "Ouais, mais tu es un peu
chiant parce que Total sur la grille
c'est temps par mois, euh bah je
partirai quoi."
Tu t'es pas fait tirer les oreilles
quand tu as chambré Pascal pro ? Parce
que Pascal pro était pas content que tu
fait un sketch sur les petits
commerçants, les petits propriétaires.
C'est ça
Non, Pascal Pro c'était un une image que
j'avais posté sur Twitter avec un bisou
nours
àab avec un bisou nours avec une
matraque. Alors c'est ça c'est assez
marrant comme
séquence parce que la blague est
carrément dans mon tweet. Donc et après
j'is marqué all copisons.
Mais c'est marqué hein dans le tweet
même quand il le diffuse sur ses news
c'est marqué et donc le mec dit mais
vous rendez compte c'est un mec de
France inter payé avec nos impôts qui
dit tous les flics sont des bâtards. Ben
non ça c'était une petite blagounette.
Enfin c'était expliqué
et non je me suis pas fait tirer les
oreilles par France Interne. Non non non
mais il rentre pas. Bah après c'est
c'est la c'est la culture du clash et
tout. La direction de France Inter
rentre pas là. Quand il dit "J'ai passé
des coups de fil, on va voir s'il
travaille demain." Jamais c'était revenu
aux oreilles.
Non. Et je supute qu'il n'est pas passé
de coup de fil d'ailleurs. Je vois pas
pourquoi Pascal pro puis il dirait quoi
? "Bonjour, c'est Pascal pro. Est-ce que
vous pouvez virer Guillaume Muris ?"
Non mais je veux bien. Je pourquoi pas
tout le monde peut faire ça appeler le
standard. Il a eu quelqu'un au standard
qui ? Oui. Oui. Ben écoutez, je note
monsieur comment dit pro. D'accord. Je
sais pas en fait
si tu devais lui trouver une qualité, ce
serait quoi ? Pascal pro. Oh bah
l'insouciance, l'audace,
ça c'est une force aussi d'en avoir
absolument rien à [__]
de dire bon ben je vais faire un plateau
équilibré, je vais prendre des gens
d'extrême droite et puis des macronistes
comme ça j'ai une bonne vision de de la
société. On est bien, on peut débattre
entre nous. C'est Ouais ouais ouais.
C'est c'est une vraie force.
Tu t'es fait tu t'es fait aussi viliper.
Ah
parce que tu avais dit que les les
petits commerçants étaient des
chouinard.
Alors intéressant aussi ça cette
séquence. Alors dans c'est un pour
rappeler c'est un texte dans ciné
mensuel qui a un un mensuel comme son
nom l'indique satrique et avec une case
qui est dédiée au panflet sur un mode un
peu planfletire. Donc j'avais écrit un
texte qui était pas du tout destiné aux
petits commerçants d'ailleurs ça a été
repris parce que évidemment il a reprise
un peu partout. Tant mieux d'ailleurs
euh en même temps Guillaume Mery
s'attaque au petit commerçant. Il y a
jamais marqué dans mon texte petit
commerçant. Mon texte il voulait juste
dire que ça me faisait marrer que des
mecs qui disent d'habitude "Ouais, faut
se faire tout seul, voilà, quand on
veut, on peut. Sortez-vous les doigts du
cul." Ce sont là du coup à chouiner pour
avoir des aides de l'État. Donc de
manière ironique, ça voulait dire "Bah
moi, je suis pour la solidarité mais
tout le temps, pas que quand ça va.
Parce que eu quand ça va, ils disent
"Non, non, ils votent Fillon et Macron
au premier tour." Ça c'était marqué dans
le texte en disant "Bah ouais, la libre
entreprise, voilà, la compétition, pas
de problème, faut gagner, faut être des
winners et puis quand ça pue un peu du
cul, ben non, on peut quand même avoir
un petit peu de pognon." C'était la
situation qui me faisait rigoler mais ça
a été pas mal repris. Oui. En mode
Million Maurice s'attaque au petits
commerçants. Ça faisait penser à un truc
que Ruffin avait dit une fois à la
tribune à l'Assemblée, je crois. Ça ça
le faisait penser quand quand des entre
quand des les grosses entreprises en
tout cas ce ce gros système financier se
cache derrière les petits. Ça le faisait
penser au curandales
au Vatican. Les mecs du Vatican disent
"Mais attendez, le petit curé de
campagne, il a rien demandé, vous
l'attaquez, vous le diffamez quand vous
parlez de ça et tout." Et en fait non,
quand on s'attaque au Vatican, au Cap
40, on s'attaque pas au commerçants du
coin de la rue ni au cur de campagne.
Tu penses que ça va se terminer comment
cette histoire ?
dans le calme, les gens vont réussir à
discuter entre eux, à trouver un terrain
d'entente où on va vraiment au clash.
Je sais pas. Non non, je sais pas.
Tu sens la température, tu prends bien
la température de ce qui se passe autour
de toi.
Bah comme tout le monde. Mais
non, je sais pas. Tu vois, il peut se
passer tellement de trucs
une pandémie qui te tombe sur le coin de
la gueule. Ça, personne n'aurait pu
prévoir un truc pareil.
Je sais que Je sais. C'est pas vrai.
C'est pas vrai. Il nombre de bouquins
qu'on a pu lire sur de de l'anticipation
avec notre modèle de société. À quoi ça
nous expose. Nombre de scientifiques ont
anticipé une pandémie à l'échelle
mondiale diffusée très rapidement.
H
oui mais là maintenant tu vois à ce
moment-là tu vois personne n'avait dit
attention dans 3
introduction au siècle des menaces
Jacques Blamont. Ouais, mais personne
n'avait dit "Dans 3 mois il y aura ça."
De ce que je veux dire, c'est que
c'est ça te tombe sur le coin de la
gueule quand même quand ça tombe sur le
coin de la gueule et trop tard. Donc euh
qu'est-ce que tu veux prédire des trucs
? Euh
prédire anticiper,
c'est comme une assurance.
Je sais que tu rêves d'une guerre
civile. Je sais, je sais que parce que
vous le voyez pas mais il est il a
gilet, il a dit "Allez, on va se
battre." Donc là, je passe mon temps à
le calmer. Alors je sais pas, on va
aller voir un cû, on va aller en
terrasse. Ah ça qu'il est énervé.
Non non, j'en sais rien. J'en sais rien.
J'en sais rien du tout. Je sais pas je
sais pas du tout du tout quand tu
Il y a une Il y a clairement de de voix
hein. Il y a
Tu sens une radicalisation chez les
gens.
Non les tiens on va parler des végan.
Trouve pas que les végan se
radicalisent.
Mais ça veut rien dire. Les végans se
radicalisent. Mais [__] on dirait on
est sur ces news là. Ça y est on a
basculé. Pascal pro enlève ton masque de
euh les végan c'est radicaliste, ça veut
rien dire du tout quand tu vois certains
qui vont caillasser des boucheries.
Bah oui mais bon, il y a toujours eu
dans tous les mouvements euh voilà euh
toutes les luttes sociales, il y a il y
a tout un spectre tout dans toutes les
sphères militantes, il y a des gens qui
font voilà qui us de la violence,
d'autres qui font signer des pétitions,
d'autres qui manifestent, d'autres qui
font tout en même temps, d'autres qui
font rien mais qui soutiennent.
Le plus effectif c'est quoi
le plus efficace, tu veux dire ?
Bah moi je pense que c'est
tu es plutôt caress une boucherie ou
non parce que je pense que ça peut être
contreproductif assez rapidement quoi.
C'est c'est le problème c'est que voilà
tout ce qui est violence casse l'image
que ça renvoie c'est évidemment tu vas
attaquer un pauvre boucher qui a rien
demandé enfin qui a rien demandé qui est
bouché mais bon puis ça à [__] qu'il
se prennent du sang sur la gueule.
Après voilà mais
où ça a toujours existé enfin voilà je
je sens pas qu'il y ait euh enfin avant
il y avait quand même des il y avait
action directe enfin il y a toujours eu
comme des c'est j'ai peut-être même on
pourrait dire si on fait l'analyse que
ça se calme en fait hein. Je suis pas
voilà faudrait faudrait voir sur le long
terme. En tout cas, non, les végans se
radicalisent. Non, peut-être il y a plus
de plus en plus de végan et ça tant
mieux, mais se radicalise, ça veut rien
dire.
Quand tu quand tu vois des des
universités où il y a des noms de prof
qui sont affichés comme X contre ou X
contre
et et que la frange de l'autre extrême
fait la même chose, ça nous amène à quoi
ça ?
Bah, c'est du spectacle hein. Ça reste
du spectacle. Après, c'est
la campagne de com au détriment de des
gens.
Bah ouais, j'ai l'impression que pendant
qu'on parle de ça, on parle pas d'autres
choses. Après, c'est un peu ce qu'on
pourrait dire sur pas mal de sujets,
mais
on en épingle des faits d'hivers ou des
ou des ou des gens qui déconnent par-ci
par là et on en fait un une actuation
avec des gens qui débattent. Alors moi
je dire très cyniquement là pour le coup
ça m'arrange pour mes chroniques. Alors
là
c'est pas la même chose. Toi tuen sors
un du lot et tu l'exposes.
Alors et ben c'est exactement ça. Je
fais exactement la même chose mais je ne
suis pas journaliste et c'est
hallucinant. D'ailleurs, c'est un vrai
problème que les gens me confondent avec
un journaliste. Dans un monde qui va
bien, personne me confondrait avec un
journaliste. Tout le monde dirait "Bah
oui, oui, c'est lui, il prend exprès ce
qu'il l'arrange pour en faire une
chronique." Bah les journalistes, ils
font ça, ils prennent exprès. Bah, il y
a il y a des exemples précis. Le café de
Sevran là, c'est un peu un peu vieux
mais le café de Sevran, c'est une de mes
chroniques, hein. Moi, je peux très bien
aller dans n'importe quel café et dire
"Regardez, c'est un café euh de de
d'horrible macho, islamophobe, tout ce
que tu veux en fait parce qu'il suffit
d'aller interroger les gens qui traînent
là et de garder ce qui t'arrange." Bah
je Oui. Oui.
Ah oui, oui. Donc je suis d'accord avec
toi.
Les journalistes sont devenus des clown
un peu comme toi.
Encore une fois, ça veut rien dire. des
journalistes qui euh Edou Plenel, Elise
Lu euh Rutel Crief, le mec qui fait des
piges à la Voie du Nord, Gaspargland,
Tabouf, ça veut rien dire. Il y a c'est
un un milieu où voilà où se côtoi des
gens avec des intérêts différents
parfois avec des convictions
différentes.
Moi, je suis assez je suis assez euh
pour aller un plus loin dans la
question, je suis assez euh
pour assumer l'objectivité. Enfin, je la
subjectivité pardon, je crois pas au
journaliste. Objectif déjà rien que dans
le so le choix du sujet, je crois qu'on
en avait parlé la dernière fois que je
suis venu ici. Ça ouais. Euh je crois
pas au à l'objectivité totale dans le
journalisme. C'est impossible. Et c'est
même pas souhaitable.
Tu devrais aller en manifestation et
faire ta chronique avec des CRS.
Ils ont pas le droit de parler. J'ai
déjà essayé. Oui oui, j'ai fait un truc
aux 50 ans des CRS et j'ai pu interroger
des CRS à la retraite parce que voilà,
ils avaient le droit de parler. Les CRS
en activité, non, ils ont pas le droit
de parler. J'ai fait quelques manifes de
flics où là ils te disent "Bah oui, mais
c'est telle personne ou telle personne
qui a le droit de parler, donc j'allais
les voir."
Euh mais oui, bah moi je Oui, j'aimerais
bien mais ils ont pas le droit et
peut-être ils ont autre chose à [__]
que de répondre à une question d'un
petit con. J'avais fait des manifes de
flic en leur demandant "Vous avez pas
peur des violences policières ?
Voilà
et c'était rigolo.
Il t'ont pas proposé
de tester sur moi
faire un peu violenté ?
Non, je sais plus comment c'était fini
mais non, ils sont toujours un peu
emmerdés pour répondre. Bah, ils te
disent que ça existe pas.
Moi, je leur dis que c'est un pléonasme.
Voilà. Mais on rigole bien.
Est-ce que Est-ce que se [__] de la
gueule des gens c'est
Non, je fais pas ça.
Écoute mes réponses. Je t'ai dit que je
faisais pas ça.
Et je te pose une question. Écoute mes
questions.
Est-ce que Est-ce que se [__] de la
gueule des gens, ça les fait changer ?
Euh
parfois oui. Ouais. Moi, ça me fait
changer. Par exemple, euh j'ai un
exemple personnel, je suis devenu
végétarien. Je l'étais pas au départ
quand j'ai commencé mes chroniques,
j'étais pas végétarien. Et puis des gens
qui m'ont dit "Bah, tu es marrant toi,
tu fais des chroniques, la planète, les
animaux, ils sont gentils et tu les
défonces dans les abattoirs." Donc on
m'a chambré et puis voilà. Ben ça m'a
fait changer.
Euh je crois pas à l'action immédiate de
quelqu'un. Ça dépend comment tu le fais,
ça dépend qui le fait. Moi ce que je
cherche à faire, c'est pas tellement ça
hein. C'est pas tellement faire changer
la vie les gens. C'est apporter mon
point de vue, un petit pas de côté, un
petit regard critique et décalé.
J'aime bien créer le doute. Voilà, si je
devais résumer ce que je fais, j'aime
bien quelqu'un qui arrive avec des
certitudes en disant bah moi je pense
que c'est ça. Ça, on pourra en parler
aussi d'où ça vient parce que ça c'est
intéressant. Moi je pense que c'est ça.
Donc moi, vous avez vu, j'ai construit
un super château là. Paf, je p lev et
tout, il y a des douves, pourrait pas
rentrer. Et toi, tu arrives avec une
petite question. Ah bon ? Un peu naïf,
tu vois. Ah bon ? Mais regardez, si je
fais ça et là
alors là, tu as deux solutions. Soit la
personne te dit "Ah ouais ! J'avais pas
vu ça comme ça. Bon ben, je vais me
démerder, je vais reconstruire un
château, je vais je vais réfléchir. Ça
n'arrive quasiment jamais." Ou soit la
personne va essayer de t'expliquer que
son château, il s'est pas cassé la
gueule. Et là c'est marrant et ça je
garde tu vois c'est mes chroniques sont
faites quasiment que de trucs comme ça
de Oui mais non mais en fait c'est parce
que
moi ce qui me fascine là-dedans, je vais
un peu tu me dis si je suis trop chiant
tu comprends son les gens vont pisser
euh ce qui me fascine làdedans, c'est
que j'entends des fois dans la bouche
des gens dans la rue lambda des éléments
de langage. Et ça c'est assez c'est
assez génial la puissance de ce truc.
C'est-à-dire
bah qu'ils ont entendu de politique.
Donc c'est-à-dire que il y a une réforme
qui va être menée. Il bossent en cabinet
avec des communiquants, des éléments de
langage. On va voilà, on va axer sur ça,
ça et ça. Ils envoient les gens dans les
médias, les politiques, les députés, les
machins. Ça passe dans la tête des gens
qui dans la rue me disent "Non mais vous
savez, cette réforme, elle est
importante parce que élément de langage
bossait en bureau de communication." Et
les gens me le disent comme si euh
c'était leur pensée. C'est pour ça je
dis souvent les gens quand je dis les
gens d'ailleurs je me mets dedans parce
qu'on a tous c réflex là. On pense
penser les trucs soit parce qu'on répète
des choses sans avoir eu le temps ou
l'envie ou le réflexe de les remettre en
question.
Euh soit parce que voilà, on a Oui, le
temps c'est soit parce qu'on a pas le on
a pas on a pas que ça à [__] quoi. Des
fois, les gens ils ont autre chose à
[__] que de faire une analyse critique
du discours.
Il y a la même chose aussi avec la
communication politique, la violence la
violence de la communication politique.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses du débat sur
l'islam gauchisme ? C'est quoi l'islam
gauchisme ?
Ça sert bien à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure, c'est voilà euh on va te
balancer un mot. Alors et ce qui est
assez rigolo avec ça, c'est qu'il y a
des gens qui m'ont dit "Mais quand on a
entendu ce mot-là, nous on croyait que
c'était juste une blague dans tes
chroniques parce que c'est un truc que
j'utilise depuis longtemps dans mes
chroniques." On dit "Oui, à France
Interre, on est des islamogauchistes" et
Blanquer d'un coup il a il en a parlé au
premier degré et après Vidal a repris le
truc.
Bah tu vois bien que le problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça. On se rend
bien compte que c'est pas ça le
problème.
L'islam politique c'est quand même un
Non mais là l'islam gauchisme donc déjà
tu fais un lien entre euh on va dire une
une idéologie de répartition des
richesses et d'organisation de la
société et une religion. Alors ça veut
dire c'est quoi ? C'est gens faudrait
définir le mot. Moi en fait le premier
truc qu'il y aura à faire c'est leur
demander de définir le mot parce que à
mon avis c'est drôle. Tu demandes à
Frédéric Vidal mais attendez c'est quoi
l'islam gauchisme ? Déjà c'est marrant
quoi. Dire c'est le lien qui peut y
avoir entre des gens de gauche et
l'islam politique. Déjà des gens de
gauche j'en connais plein qui sont
hâtés. Euh c'est c'est c'est un espèce
de mot balancé comme ça. On parle on en
parle pendant 3 qu jours. Il y a les
débats sur LCI.
C'est news pour
c'est dans la c'est dans la les 5
minutes d'après et cetera et cetera. On
va parler de ce trucl et puis ça passe
quoi.
Je vais prendre une question internet.
Vas-y. Question internet. Pardon. J'ai
soif, il fait chaud ici.
Attends, c'est pas fini. Montre un peu
la température.
Alors, c'est une question interrogatoire
de police.
Non non non, on va pas te frapper
aujourd'hui.
Et
question d'internet. Est-ce que tu
serais capable de t'humilier dans une de
dans une chronique autant que tu
humilies les autres ?
Bah, on va revenir à toujour la même
question. J'humilie pas les autres.
Ben non.
Est-ce que tu peux comprendre qu'il y en
a qui puissent percevoir ça comme de
l'humiliation ?
Ah oui, c'est pour ça que j'explique que
çaen est pas que c'est pas de
l'humiliation. C'est et évidemment avec
plaisir. Oui, la réponse est oui.
Si on accepte le fait que j'humilie pas
les gens. Mais évidemment euh je veux
bien faites une chronique avec moi. Ben
c'est un peu ce que tu fais de me poser
des questions, de me remettre en
question de à chaque fois que je dis un
truc qui se contredit d'être là. Enfin
c'est tu es en train de faire une
chronique dison. Foiré.
Autre non. Autre question. La moralité
et la moquerie font-elle un bon ménage ?
Euh oui, Kanton ça hein.
Oui. Question suivante. Non, j'en sais
rien. J'en sais rien.
C'est quoi la moralité ?
J'en sais rien que c'est la moralité.
C'est quoi ? Celle de la fontaine ou euh
ou celle de est-ce que c'est la moralité
moralisatrice ou est-ce que c'est
faudrait pareil, je suis désolé, j'ai
c'est l'impression de fuir ces
questionslà, mais c'est juste que pour
en pour répondre précisément, faudrait
définir les termes quoi.
Est-ce que est-ce que
moi je donne alors ce je vais essayer de
jouer le jeu à fond du truc, mais en
précisant alors ce qu'on peut appeler la
morale, j'imagine que comme à chaque fin
de mes chroniques, je mets un petit un
petit truc de fin qui résume un peu mon
avis, ça doit être ça dont la personne
veut parler.
Bon bah c'est ma morale que je donne,
c'est mon avis, c'est mon point de vue.
Donc oui et après donc ça je suis
quasiment payé pour ça. Ça me plaît de
le faire mais c'est c'est ça qu'on me
demande en gros. Et euh et la moquerie.
Oui, j'adore chambrer, j'adore être
chambré, j'adore j'appelle ça du
taquinage artistique.
Je trouve que c'est une manière de se
respecter justement et pas de s'humilier
quoi.
L'autodérision.
L'autodérision. Oui, c'est pour ça qu'on
s'appelle aussi les islamogachistes.
On est conscient, enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'on est conscient de
notre travers et euh autant que faire ce
peu et puis moi, je suis ça me
Est-ce que est-ce que tu
des humoristes qui se prennent au
sérieux ? C'est je pense il y a pas
grand-chose de pire quoi.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu as essayé de te
mettre à la place des gens qui te
perçoivent comme le gauchot de service ?
Ouais, ouais, bien sûr. Bah, je
comprends.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ils se sentent
agressés ? Pourquoi ils se sentent
coincés ? Pourquoi ils se sentent sans
médias ? Pourquoi ils se réfugient tous
il
Ça c'est drôle que ça. Ouais. Ouais.
Parce que
pourquoi il se réfugi il se réfugie à
vous mettre tous dans le même sac en
disant les islamogauchistes voilà ils
écoutent pas notre point de vue, on n
pas entendu. Est-ce que tu as essayé de
te mettre à leur place et de comprendre
leur leur cheminement leur cheminement
psychologique ?
Oui parce que une de mes passions dans
la vie, c'est pas des conneries, c'est
de répondre aux gens. Alors, je le fais
pas sur les messages publics parce que
c'est trop chronophage puis j'ai pas
puis ça donne tout de suite un aspect
représentatif aux réponses culture du
clash et cetera, mais les messages
privés de gens qui m'aiment pas et même
quand ils sont très agressifs, j'ai eu
des messages qui commencent par fils de
[__] et et 3h après qui se termine, bah
merci, c'était cool d'échanger avec toi.
Jamais de menace de mort
par message privé. Non, après sur
Twitter et tout, mais j'avoue les
mentions, je regarde plus.
Donc euh par message privé, j'ai pas
souvenir. Non, mais donc je me mets à
leur place. Enfin, l'échange
m'intéresse. Moi, le débat d'idée
m'intéresse et ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de savoir jusqu'où on n'est pas
d'accord.
Et ça c'est assez passionnant parce que
forcément, tu arrives à à forcément à
trouver des points communs, même si
c'est une personne, j'en sais rien,
d'extrême droite. Pourquoi elle ressent
ça ? Pourquoi elle pense que euh des
gens qui fuient la guerre sont à danger
? Enfin, il y a des choses à creuser
là-dedans. Donc en fait, tout le temps,
je me mets à leur place. tout le temps.
Ça m'intéresse, même en allant sur le
terrain interroger les gens, j'ai j'ai
un vrai intérêt pour ce qu'ils vont dire
malgré ma mon mon tropisme de de petit
con sarcastique. Donc oui, et pour
répondre plus précisément à ta question,
ce qui nous reproche essentiellement, je
crois que c'est parce qu'on est payé par
eux et je peux le comprendre. Donc
tu as pas senti qu' qui
Attends, je finis. Donc, j'avais lancé
euh à un moment donné les gens qui me
disaient ça, je leur disais "Je
comprends, je suis d'accord avec vous,
je vous rembourse. Envoie-moi une
enveloppe timbrée et je te rembourse la
part de redevance que je te coûte." Donc
bah évidemment, c'était 0,0. Donc le
timbre coûtait plus cher que donc j'ai
jamais eu d'emplope timbré mais j'étais
prêt à rembourser.
Il faut discuter, il faut il faut
discuter avec eux
mais il y a pas de eux et nous hein. Il
y a pas de deux camp qui s'affrontent
tous sur une planète perdu au milieu de
nulle part. C'est pas le moment de sur
la gueule. Je sais que tu rêves d'une
guerre civile mais non.
Je rêve pas d'une guerre civil.
Il y aura pas Feriew.
Est-ce que tu sens pas en fait une
polarisation extrême des forces ? Est-ce
que tu tu les sens pas ce ce terré euh
que ce soit l'ultra gauche ou ultra
qu dans la société ? Pardon, je te
coupe. Non mais quand dans la société,
il y a pas eu de polarisation des
forces, il y a toujours eu polarisation
des forces. Avant, il y avait même
carrément
guerre froide entre deux énormes blocs
qui qui se regardaient de Traviol. Donc
donc oui, bah oui,
c'est toujours le cas.
C'est toujours le cas en plus. pas les
aspects ont changé mais donc oui mais il
y a toujours eu ça mais comme on est le
nez dedans j'ai l'impression qu'on
évidemment le ressent plus fort on se
dire oh là là je suis en train de de mal
tourner bah en gros c'est ça tourne mal
depuis le début cette histoire
d'aventure humaine là c'est chelou non
non
donc je méfie pas mal de ça quo du
du oh là là vous rendez compte comment
c'est maintenant avant c'était mieux
Bah ça les rapports de force.
D'ailleurs, je reviens à la promo de mon
bouquin. Non mais pourquoi j'ai voulu
faire ce parallèle entre un bouffon de
cours et euh et ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
c'est pas trop mal écrit d'ailleurs,
c'est gentil mais c'est que la structure
de du pouvoir a pas changé, c'est que
c'est vertical. Donc les mêmes
structures. Donc il y a les courtisans,
on le voit, il y en a un pl tort les les
petits rigolos 2e siècle. C'est qui les
courtisans maintenant ? C'est les
courtisans c'est qui ? les politiques.
Ouais, les politiques, les journalistes
et qui les
les éditorialistes. Enfin, somme de
d'éditorialistes, pas de BFM
dans le JDD, enfin partout des
courtisans, on les connaît quoi.
Ils ont pas de réflexe de déglition.
Le réflexe de quoi ?
Déglition.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
Je je vois pas ce que tu veux dire.
Aval.
Ah oui, d'accord. J'avais pas compris la
métaphore. Euh non, ben je enfin je ce
qui les guide, ça va revenir à ce qu'on
ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure sur les
les députés qui sont à ce poste-là. Donc
c'est difficile une fois que tu es à ce
poste-là de renoncer. Enfin, je vois pas
Christophe Barbier dire demain non mais
je dis de la merde depuis 20 ans,
désolé, je vais aller élever des
chèvres. Je rêverai à jour d'un truc qui
se passe comme ça en direct. Je rêver la
politique qui en plein discours, en
plein débat disent non pardon. Non non
mais je dis de la merde. Non non vous
avez raison là je dis de la merde. Euh
capable de faire ça genre la salle il
est capable même genre la salle il est
pas capable.
Bien sûr que si.
Non il est pas capable.
Tu l'as eu genre la salle ? Il est venu
ici ou pas ?
Oui on l' on l'a eu. On l'a tourné.
Faut un bon inesson hein.
Ah ouais
moi quand j'interroge moi il faut
vraiment mettre le micro aprèsin. Ah
il faut le laisser parler gentiment.
Ouais ouais
il a le temps. Le harcèlement en ligne
toi tu adores te faire insulter sur les
réseaux. J'ai pas dit que j'adorais mais
ça fait partie du jeu. Ouais,
c'est un jeu pour toi. Est-ce que tu as
un conseil à donner à ceux qui sont
harcelés ? Un conseil d'humoriste pour
pour résister à à sa question.
Il y en a qu'un. Il y en a qu'un. C'est
de pas aller voir.
On est forcément
Moi, j'ai tendance à utiliser la
métaphore des plumes de canard. Donc
moi, c'est vrai que quand je vois ça,
j'ai tendance souvent les gens, ils
disent "Ouais, tu as une armure." Mais
en fait, je trouve une armure, ça
encaisse le coup quand même les plumes
de canard. Tu vois ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire l'eau, elle elle pénètre
même pas dans le dans le plumage du cas,
ça glisse quoi. Et euh
mais malgré tout, je pense que ça fait
jamais plaisir de toute façon de lire
des saloperies à longueur de temps sur
toi. Donc ouais, le conseil que
le conseil que j'aurais donné, c'est de
pas aller voir si vraiment on peut pas
s'empêcher d'aller voir quand ça va trop
loin de porter plainte parce que c'est
du virtuel mais derrière il y a des il y
a des il y a des vraies personnes.
Il y en a qui le font et ils gagnent
systématiquement. Bon, faut avoir du
temps. C'est c'est aussi coûteux. Ouais.
Du pognon aussi un peu. Ouais. Ouais.
C'est c'est pas évident. Mais voilà,
c'est peut-être les deux seuls conseils
que je donnerai. Ouais.
Mais sinon, tu as une parole publique.
Malheureusement
euh c'est ce qui va arriver. Ouais.
C'est une constante.
Est-ce que tu
Et surtout sur pardon, je désolé mais tu
as des réseaux sociaux plus violents que
d'autres. Twitter étant le pire. Twitter
si tu postes "J'ai faim" trois tweets
après tu as nazi rend la redevance quo
tu vois.
Donc bon
enfin moi je prends ça comme une
constante
quasi parfois quand je vois des
réactions quand je tombe dessus je me
dis bon ben j'ai bien fait mon taf.
Quand Pascal pro demande ma démission
bah j'ai bien fait mon boulot quoi.
C'est OK. Cool, je suis au bon endroit.
Ça tombe bien, il est là.
Mais avec plaisir, j'ai pas de souci.
Question internet, est-ce que tu as déjà
eu des problèmes d'éthique ?
J'ai pas souvenir.
Non, j'ai une sorte de petite
déontologie, tu vois, j'y suis même pas
tenu parce que je suis humoriste à
limite, mais j'essaie de pas interroger
les gens qui me reconnaissent
parce que j'ai pas envie. De toute
façon, ça serait nul. Tu vois les gens
qui me reconnaissent dans la rue
parce que tu sais jamais s'ils vont
jouer un jeu. Enfin non, ça mais c'est
même pas une déontologie en vrai. Non,
j'essay quand même de te répondre à tes
questions sur l'éthique mais bon ça
marche pas. Non, j'ai jamais eu de
problème d'éthique. Non,
des questionnements sur ma position au
sein de ce ce truc. Oui, ça c'est
permanent. Mais d'éthique. Qu'est-ce que
tu appellerais éthique ? Excepter du
pognon de gens.
Bah le truc c'est si on te demande de
faire un ménage, on te demande de faire
un ménage par exemple pour l'industrie
de la viande.
Ben non mais
en plus tu prends exprès le truc. Non
mais quel que soit Non, j'ai toujours
refusé de jouer pour les parties
politiqu pour les végan.
Quoi ? Quoi ?
Tu ferais un ménage pour les végan ?
Euh alors j'ai fait l'inverse, j'ai joué
mon spectacle pour elle mais c'est pas
eux qui me l'ont demandé. J'ai dit je
envie de vous aider. Je sais pas de
quelle manière. Mieux ça serait
j'organise une un spectacle, vous faites
la billetterie et vous prenez le pognon.
Ça j'ai fait ouais mais c'est pas là
pour le coup j'ai rien gagné. C'était
encore heureux quoi.
Alors je vais te
un ménage. Non j'ai j'ai même je refuse
toujours de jouer pour les partis
politiques quel qu'il soit. J'ai refusé
de jouer en Chine. On m'avait proposé
trois dates et
c'était l'institut français je pense
hein. Et ça ça me faisait chier de
jouer.
Ça faisait peur.
Non, c'est pas la peur, c'est de me dire
j'aurais pas Moi, j'essaie de faire que
des trucs que je peux assumer quoi. Et
je me seris dit là je joue youi, on
s'amuse et puis tu as des mecs qui se
prennent des balles dans la nuque.
J'étais pas à l'aise avec ça. J'ai dit
non.
Voilà mon éthique. Mais bon, je peux me
permettre d'avoir cette éthique là parce
que je gagne bien ma vie, tu vois. Je
peux me permettre de refuser des ménages
parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas besoin de
tune. Je gagne
toujours à 6500 € par mois chez France
Inter.
6005 ça. Je suis toujours à 200 balles
la chronique
200 balles netes. Donc on fait 4 par
semaine. Il y a 4 semaines. 4 x 4 8 Non,
c'est beaucoup moins 6500 balles. Où
est-ce que tu avais vu ça ? Il y a un
article de l'Bayé qui disait ça mais
c'est parce que le mec il avait fait la
somme à l'époque je jouais trois fois
par semaine de mon spectacle donc ouais
ça faisait une somme où tu disais bah
bon là c'est moi mais je me plains pas
évidemment je gagne bien ma vie en plus
je gagne ma vie en faisant des blagues
et en racontant des conneries donc bon
ça va quoi.
Alors je vais écrire un commentaire de
du forum. Ouais, vas-y.
Définition de l'islamogauchisme.
Ah, vas-y, vas-y. Tiens,
c'est une forme de bienpensance de
gauche qui vont par peur de passer pour
des affreux racistes et xénophobes
défendre coûte que coûte la religion de
l'islam, malgré les problèmes qu'elle
peut potentiellement poser, ne veulent
pas accepter la critique des religions
et refusent de faire le lien entre
immigration, entre parenthèses, des pays
musulmans en une bonne partie, et la
montée de l'insécurité, entre
parenthèses, violence physique sur
personne.
Question. Du coup, il en pense quoi de
l'islam gauchisme ?
Bah, il y a plusieurs trucs dans
plusieurs éléments dans sa
critique des religions.
Je fais exprès de poser ce type de
question pour crever l'abscès.
Oh, il y a pas d'abscès, hein. Euh, il y
a plusieurs trucs. Faudrait que tu
relises. Je crois que la dernière
partie, c'est le lien entre immigration
et insécurité.
Bon, ça c'est balayé par X étude. On va
pas revenir dessus, ça c'est de la
merde. Euh critique des religions.
Enfin, moi je suis plutôt sur cette
thématique là. Ouais. critique de toutes
les religions, ça j'ai déjà fait.
D'ailleurs, à chaque fois que tu fais
une chronique sur une religion, tu as
les personnes croyantes choquées qui
viennent te dire "Tu oserais pas faire
ça sur les autres ?" Bon, la chance que
j'ai, c'est que
tu as jamais dit "Jésus est un [__] ?"
Non, c'est c'est un collègue qui a fait
cette chanson là. Mais ça c'est pareil,
ça a été repris mais il y avait une
raison pour laquelle il avait fait ça.
Je crois que c'était une série qui avait
été interdite au Brésil parce que ça
représentait Jésus euh gay et puis euh
je sais plus exactement, j'ai plus les
détails, mais en gros euh ça avait été
censuré. Donc il en avait parlé parce
que c'est parce qu'on est des
chroniqueurs et on chronique ce qui se
passe dans la société. On fait du
commentaire d'actu. Euh là en
l'occurrence c'était une chanson. Donc
il a fait son travail quoi. Pour revenir
à la question donc le lien entre
immigration et insécurité, ça c'est
l'éternel le truc qui est répété sans
arrêt et évidemment c'est de la merde.
Euh la critique des religions, moi j'ai
l'impression alors si être
islamogachiste, c'est de pas critiquer
l'islam, bon ben je suis pas
islamuchiste parce que j'ai fait les
chroniques surtout au moment de Charlie
et tout. On en a fait plein. Je fais le
salon des musulmans, truc sur Taric
Ramadan. Enfin, on en a on a fait les
blagues sur le voilà sur la thématique.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y avait au début
au début du commentaire ?
Ils viennent de me faire sauter la
ligne.
On est censuré. Non, il y avait un truc.
Ah, attends, attends, attends. C'est une
forme de bienpensance de gauche.
Voilà, déjà bien pensance c'est
Est-ce que tu as pas l'impression qu'il
y a des senseurs en ce moment ? des mé
des gens qui s'estiment détenteurs de la
vérité vraie et qui imposent ça à tout
le monde.
Mais est
bah c'est leur perception. Je retour
bah non, j'ai pas cette impression là.
Non non.
Dans l'audiovisuel.
Dans l'audiovisuel dans dans on va dire
dans le dans la caste médiatique il est
vaste he le champ médiatique quand même.
Ça va de ces news à la radio libertaire.
Tu vas peut-être pouvoir trouver ton
bonheur quoi.
Question internet. Est-ce que tu penses
que tu pousses le bouchon un peu trop
loin ?
OK, on est sur du jeu de mot, ça me va.
Oui, réponse est oui. C'est mon métier.
Autre question internet. Est-ce que ça
t'est déjà arrivé de tourner tes propres
idées, tes propres valeurs en dérision
sur le véganisme par exemple ?
Euh oui oui. Bah oui, mais ça on le
fait. Bah la chance qu'on a aussi, c'est
qu'on travaille en groupe. Donc les
autres se privent pas de de se [__] de
ma gueule avec
avec mes mes histoires de protection
animale. Donc Ouais. Ouais. Oui. Oui,
évidemment. Oui. Bah ça, il suffit
d'écouter enf pas obligé mais suffit
d'écouter les chroniques. Oui. Oui.
La la question c'était cela
t'arrive-t-il de tourner en ridicule tes
propres idées ? Végétarien gauchisme ?
Alors, autre question internet. Que
pensent-t-il du poids qu'ont les médias
dans les élections présidentielles ?
Bah, difficilement, c'est difficilement
quantifiable quand même, ça. C'est
euh qu'on les médias,
on dit souvent, bah c'est un peu la
discussion qu'on avait eu aussi la
dernière fois que je suis venu ici, mais
que c'est les médias qui ont fait
Macron. Moi je pense plutôt que c'est
Macron qui a utilisé les médias et de
toute façon comme c'est le même
écosystème chacun avait intérêt à ce que
ça se passe comme ça.
C'est c'est un peu la même chose mais la
fois le plus complexe que les médias ont
fait Macron.
Euh
là, ce qui est intéressant, c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer sur le net, je
trouve, parce qu'ils sont en train de se
dire que la campagne va peut-être se
jouer pas mal sur les réseaux sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur les les
plateformes, bah YouTube et puis Twitch
Macron chez les youtubeurs, tu en penses
quoi ?
Ouais, voilà. Bah c'est c'est un
positionnement ça. Et et en plus comme
ils veulent stratégie
Bien sûr, c'est une stratégie. Ouais. Et
c'est intéressant de les voir euh les
voir manœuvrer quoi. Dès qu'il y en a un
qui va en plus tout le monde. Mais
l'enchant était un peu précurseur
là-dessus en montant sa chaîne YouTube.
Alors du coup, ils sont tous euh un peu
merde, on est en retard. Euh chacun
essaie de se positionner là-dessus. Euh
après les médias, est-ce que est-ce que
c'est encore les médias qui font
l'élection ? Oui, certainement. Tu sais,
c'est la question de l'influence, quoi.
La question de l'influence, je je
saurais pas y répondre. Je sais jamais
quoi répondre parce que
moi moi je j'ai pas l'impression d'être
influent. Et des fois, on me dit "Oui,
mais par exemple euh c'est un scandale,
le matin dans la matinale, il y a
Dominique Se qui est euh euh le mec des
échos, donc qui est très libéral
économiquement, tout ça. Mais alors,
est-ce que Dominique il a de l'influence
? Je sais pas. Moi, je fais plus de
vues, mes chroniques font plus de vues
que Dominix. Donc, est-ce que j'ai plus
d'influence que Dominique ? J'en sais
rien en fait. Je sais pas.
Est-ce qu'on a déjà essayé de te couper
la chic comme on avait fait du temps des
guignoles pendant une élection
présidentielle ou avant ? Est-ce qu'on
t'a pas demandé ? Non, tu ne parles plus
des élections.
Non, non. Ben non, mais de toute façon,
tu le saurais parce qu'on enfin je dis
on mais je partirai immédiatement.
Ouais. Non mais même c'est pas dans leur
intérêt de faire ça la direction de
France interre enfin je je pense enfin
ils ont besoin aussi de de ils ont
besoin de notre émission pour comme une
soupape aussi de de respiration dans
dans un peu lactue anxiogène et ce genre
de choses. Enfin je crois moi je suis
pas directeur des programmes. Après
chacun son boulot mais je pense qu'on
occupe une case qui qui est qui est qui
peut être utile pour eux aussi. Donc
bon,
Darmanin, c'est un de tes sujets
préférés.
Ouais. Darmanin, c'est intéressant parce
que il est venu dans la matinale quand
vous allez la chronique avec Charline et
il avait décidé de pas rire. Alors donc
dès le début, il était bah on le voit
sur la vidéo froid, les yeux dans les
yeux, le défi et c'est ça m'a fait
marrer quoi. Je me suis dit ce mec là il
aspire à les les hautes fonctions et et
là il se dit les deux humoristes qu'on
est personne quoi. Sharine Valonacker
Guillaume Muriste, tu imagines ?
C'est dangereux un bouffon quand il
Ah je sais pas je sais pas tu vois.
Et et donc il a il nous a voilà défié du
regard pendant toute la chronique. Il a
une petite punchline de fin, je sais pas
qui s'il avait préparé ou pas, qui était
pas dégueu de dire qu'on était pas
drôle, je sais pas quoi. C'est pas mal.
Et euh et ouais, personnage intéressant
parce que vraiment
puant d'ambition quoi. Vraiment puant
d'ambition quoi.
Ton ton ministre préféré en ce moment
c'est lequel ?
C'est dur, il y en a plein.
Verran, c'est c'est pas ton ministre
préféré ?
Verran, il a Verrant, il passe bien. Il
a la bonne gueule. Ouais. Ouais. Il est
pas mal sur les plateaux. C'est un peu
le
Mais biceps et cetera. Non, c'est pas
mon prf. Non les je me demande par
exemple Barbara Pompili, je me demande
comment tu dors quoi. Je me demande
comment tu te dis pas chaque seconde non
mais je crois que là je fais de la
merde. Je je vraiment elle arrive les
néonicotnoïdes elle arrive à dire mais
en plus on le voit enfin ça rejoint
encore une fois ce qu'on dit tout à
l'heure tout le monde l'a vu cette vidéo
pendant 2 minutes elle dit non mais il y
a pas moyen. Et là elle arrive enfin
c'est fou quoi. C'est ça me fascine un
peu ça hein. Tu me poses la question de
l'éthique,
d'avaler les couleuvres.
Ouais, mais comment tu fais pour vivre
avec toi-même après ? Parce que au bout
d'un moment quand même, tu t'endors le
soir, tu fermes les yeux, tu es tout
seul avec toi-même. C'est pour la
France.
Mais est-ce qu' est-ce qu'ils se disent
ça ? Tu crois ? Ouais. Ouis, peut-être.
C'est pour la France et je fais bien.
J'espère. J'imagine qu'ils se disent ça.
Je les vois pas faire, je les ai encore
bien [__] J'imagine qu'ils se disent
"Non, non, mais là, je crois que c'est
bien." Mais en même temps, ils y croient
pas.
C'est enfin c'est ça me paraît dingue.
Donc Pompili
Ouais, ça ça me ça ça me fascine.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme Bah Vidal
Vidal, c'est marrant en ce moment parce
que elle balance le truc d'islamogisme.
Macron il la convoque pour dire "Ouais,
non mais calme-toi parce que tu dis de
la merde." Elle elle dit "Ouais, c'est
bon, j'ai compris." Elle fait une
interview au JDD.
Elle dit "Le problème, j'ai j'ai compris
là. Le problème des étudiants là, c'est
islam gauchisme.
Question question d'internet. Euh,
penses-tu être allé trop loin sur une
chronique et d'avoir regretté ?
Euh, ça m'est pas arrivé. Non, je non
non non.
Euh
non, j'ai par contre j'ai un autre
exemple, j'ai déjà
euh
refusé de faire une chronique pour un
truc assez précis. Là, c'est vraiment un
truc très très précis. Justement sur une
manife de flic. J'ai fait une manife de
flic, cit à Bastie, je crois. Et donc je
reviens avec mon sujet qui était voilà
les violences policières, les flics,
tout ça. Et c'était le jour où il y a eu
l'attentat la préfecture qui a un mec
qui a qui a dessé des flics au couteau
là. Et donc moi je reviens avec ce truc
là.
Je crois même qu'il travaillait dedans.
Ouais, il travaillit dedans. Ouais. Bon,
ça tu dois plus connaître que moi ce
truc là. En tout cas, c'était voilà et
je reviens avec ça moi à 13h et le truc
tombe à 13h30 14h quoi. Donc ce que je
disais dans ma chronique, je le pensais
toujours mais il y avait une question de
d'essence. Enfin je je l'aurais pas
assumé quoi. J'aurais pas pu faire un
truc en me foutant de la gueule des
flics sachant que il y en avait qui
baignait dans leur sang. Enfin c'est
donc je les tge foutu la poubelle.
Mais c'est un réflexe voilà de
plus de peut-être de déontologie. Non,
je sais pas, c'est même pas de la
déontologie, mais c'est je l'aurais pas
assumé tout simplement. Donc ça c'est
Mais donc je l'ai pas regretté puisque
je l'ai pas faite. Je pense que je
l'aurais faite. Je l'aurais regretté.
Ouais. J'ai pas de souvenir. Non, j'ai
pas de j'ai pas de Non parce que de
toute façon ce que je fais porte pas
trop à conséquence. Donc
regretter euh
Oh, je pense que tu peux me choper. J'en
ai fait tellement que tu peux à mon avis
m'en choper pas mal et faire des arrêts
sur les pauses et me dire là tu es fier
du truc. Ouais, je pense je te dirais
oui bon là c'est sûr mais au point de
regretter non
mélanchant chez Anouna, ça ça vous
choque ? Question d'internet ?
Ouais ouais moi oui. Pas choqué c'est
pas le mot pas choqué mais oui enfin oui
je l'ai regardé pour te dire je me suis
dit tiens bah voyons voir. Et puis c'est
en fait c'est un piège on en revient
toujours au même problème. Tu tu peux
pas les
être plus fort que cette structure là.
C'est une émission qui est faite pour du
divertissement, de l'entertainment, du
clash. C'est pas une émission qui est
faite pour exposer des idées. Donc soit
tu vas pour faire la bagarre et ça va
pas être intéressant. Sachant que tu
risques de perdre parce que en face ils
sont pleins, ils te coupent la parole.
Enfin, c'est c'est pas c'est pas la
démocratie quoi. Enfin, tu vois, c'est
donc non, ça me choque pas mais je
trouve ça complètement con et je
comprends la logique de dire "On parle à
tout le monde donc je veux pas être
snob, je vais chez Hanouna mais je pense
que personne n'y gagne."
Ouais. J'étais je fait blaser. Non non
mais voilà, je pense vraiment ça quoi.
J'ai regardé par curiosité et je me suis
dit ah bah voilà oui, j'aurais pas dû
regarder.
Une question de de capitaine Bob, une
opinion sur l'absence de diversité
d'opinions sur France inter.
Lui il doit voter à droite.
Euh je je vais voter en touche mais
j'écoute pas France Interre. Je sais
pas. Il faudrait qu'il me qu'il me
peut-être qu' peut-être qu'il a raison
mais je sais pas de quoi il parle. On
est considéré comme une radio euh plutôt
de centre gauche, mais tu sais euh
Finkerview est considéré comme une
chaîne complotiste, donc on ne sait pas,
tu sais tout.
Tu sais les gens qui jugent,
non, je en vrai, je
j'espère qu'ils ont une bonne assurance
parce que je peux dire que l'avocat
l'avocat, je vais te dire, on s'est
serré la ceinture, je te jure, pour
avoir un budget avocat.
En plus, c'est un avocé, un bureau de
son palier là, il y a un cabinet dire
qu'ils vont ils vont bien prendre. Alors
non non, c'est c'est vrai que j'ai par
exemple, j'écoute pas la matinale parce
que j'ai pas envie de me réveiller avec
une interview de de politique qui va
faire ça comme enfin ça m'intéresse pas,
je préfère mettre de la musique.
Donc je sais pas, je sais alors il
faudrait je sais pas, il faudrait que ça
soit un peu plus poussé cette question
et pas l'image qu'on a de France
Interre.
Alors question question d'internet. Que
pensent-il du complotisme ? Bah c'est un
poil, un mot valise pour mettre tout et
n'importe quoi pour euh parfois gagner
un débat sans trop se fouler. Ça a un
peu remplacé le l'argument euh le le
point Godwin quoi, de dire "Tu es
complotiste, c'est un peu maintenant
dire euh tu es nazi". Euh par contre
c'est une c'est c'est une tendance qu'on
voit de plus en plus.
Pourquoi ? parce que les gens cherchent
des réponses. Moi, j'ai regardé Holdup
euh qui est un film déjà beaucoup trop
long, hein. Ah les gars, faites du
complot mais faites-le en 1h5 quoi.
2h40, je sais pas quoi. Non, puis en
plus faut une thèse, tu vois, un bon
film complotiste, par exemple, le truc
sur les pyramides là. Voilà, c'était
bien foutu des belles images. Il y avait
une thèse. Voilà le truc los Change là
sur 11 septembre très complotiste mais
bien foutu. Mais là non, hold up, faut
rebosser la la forme. Euh mais non mais
quand tu sais pas, tu cherches des
réponses. Donc donc le premier mec, il
va dire "Mais si, en réalité c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça. Déjà, je
pense qu'il faut s'arrêter là. Déjà, il
faut dire non, ça
rien que la musique en fond." Tu as
compris ?
Ouais. Il y a une phrase géniale dans
Holdup, c'est euh "Je m'engouffre dans
un taxi, ce sont des véritables
décodeurs de la société. Les chauffeurs
sont des véritables décodeur." Et là,
j'ai dit "C'est génial moi vraiment
c'est là, c'est ce que je fais tous les
jours. Je vais sur le marché,
les gens qui que je vais rencontrer sont
des véritables décodeurs de la société."
Ouais.
Hm.
Donc je m' donc pour résumer, je m'en
méfie quand même de l'accusation
complotiste qui tombe qui tombe parfois
trop vite. Je je pour évidemment la
remise en question et le doute critique
sur tous les sujets. Après, si c'est
pour exposer d'autres certitudes
euh farfelu, oui, enfin ou dangereuse.
Les taxis peuvent être une très très
bonne source d'information. Ah oui oui
vo
tu sais comment quand ils vont chercher
les politiques après leur beuveries.
Oui, ils les font parler. Mais qu'est-ce
que ça vaut la parole d'un
écoute, il les écoute, ça peut être
Ouais, mais pour en faire une source
dans un documentaire qui se veut
révélateur de de la vérité, c'est
compliqué, je trouve ça compliqué.
Est-ce que tu as un avis sur le
nucléaire ? Question de 1 G.
Oui. Oh là, j'ai des débats avec des
copains là-dessus. Ouais. Euh contre
contre
pourquoi contre ? pour une raison
simple, le débat sur le nucléaire, c'est
ça, c'est un copain Florian Gouttier qui
m'avait expliqué comment comment
les gens débattent, comment les gens
argumentent. Ce qui il m'avait dit un
truc hyper intéressant. Je crois qu'il
le tient d'un bouquin. Mais en gros, si
tu veux débattre du sujet du nucléaire,
ce qu'il faudrait c'est mettre tous les
arguments sur une table. Tu mets tous
les arguments, tout ce que tu entends,
même des trucs farfelus, tout. Tu
choisis les arguments valides. Tu
élimines les autres. Tu vois, tous ceux
qui sont pas valides, tu les élimines et
tu gardes euh bah production de CO2,
enfin c'est ça fait moins de CO2, c'est
un argument valide, il y a un problème
avec les déchets nucléaires, argument
valide et le positionnement des gens sur
ce truclà va être la hiérarchie des
arguments dans leur tête. Et moi, la
hiérarchie des arguments sur le
nucléaire dans ma tête, c'est euh
problème de sécurité et euh pour
l'instant pas de solution pour les
déchets nucléaires à part les enterrêts
profonds et démerdez-vous. Donc moi je
le mets ça, je le mets euh au début.
Alors ça ça n'annule pas l'argument sur
évidemment ça produit moins de CO2 et et
on a on aurait besoin de ça en ce moment
de produire moins de CO2. Mais mais moi
dans ma hiérarchie, dans ma tête, je
trouve que c'est le le risque est trop
gros.
Je sais pas si j'ai bien répondu. J'ai
essayé de bien synthétiser.
Et si et si je te dis
non, tout le monde pion de toute façon
ça fait une heure qu'il pion. Mais
non, il rigole, je rigole.
C'est vrai que toi tu pionces toi. Non
non
non. contre contre
contre
euh mais contre à court terme ou à moyen
terme ?
À moyen à court terme, tu peux pas tu
vas pas fermer les centrales de main.
Donc de toute façon, c'est du long terme
même le nucléaire. Donc à contre à long
terme
quand quand tuas tu as essayé de
discuter de ça avec des politiques, ils
sont ils sont connaissent. Enfin après
on va dire que j'y connais pas grand
chose non plus mais c'est un débat
idéologique avec les politiques. Tuas
les politiques qui vont me dire
alors une question de Grégoire.
Grégoire qu'est-ce qu'il veut savoir
? Il dit point d'interrogation castor en
2022.
Ah je sais pas.
Est-ce que tu vas faire barrage ?
Non mais moi je fais pas barrage. Je je
déjà vote tout le temps parce que je
considère que c'est pas
Est-ce que tu vas Est-ce que tu as voté
Macron ? voter Macron au second tour.
Ouais. Ouais.
Tu vas revoter Macron s'il se présente
pas. Il va pas se présenter.
S'il se présente pas.
Euh non, mais j'ai voté Macron contre Le
Pen parce que je préfère Le Pen à
Macron. Je m'attendais pas à ce que il
marche autant sur les thématiques
d'extrême droite. Là, j'ai avou j'étais
très naïf comme pas mal de gens mais ça
excuse pas.
Lesquelles lesquelles thématiques
d'extrême droite ?
Moi, il y a moi pour il y a il y a un
avant et un après l'aquarius. Il y a un
avant et un après l'Aquarius. le bateau
d'OS Méditerranée qui avait qui est au
large de l'Italie. Salvini dit "Foutez
le camp Salvini mec d'extrême droite".
Et là bon bah il cherche un port pour
accueillir le bateau. Les Corses disent
"Bah nous on veut bien le prendre
Bonifacio et tout quoi." Et Macron donne
pas son accord pour que
euh les les gens soient secourus,
débarqués et secourus qui reçoivent de
de l'aide quoi. Donc ils vont débarquer
à Valence je crois.
Donc il se tapent 3 jours de bateau en
plus. Enfin, pour moi, à partir de ce
moment-là, tu peux plus être macroniste.
Termine. Même le macroniste qui croyait
encore en disant "Mais si
c'est de l'humanisme quand même." Non,
tu vois bien que non.
Ça pour moi il y a un avant et un après
ça.
Donc 2022
et puis après tout ce qui s'en est suivi
hein. Tir de flashball dans la gueule,
débat sur l'islam gauchisme,
coup de couteau dans les tentes. Enfin
ça coup de couteau dans les tentes.
Peleteuse. Peteuse.
Peleteuse quoi. Non mais même ils ont
même plus leuse.
Ouais j'ai vu j'ai vu. D'ailleurs, je
crois techniquement c'est pas une
pteuse.
C'est une pteuse, il y a une Non, c'est
enfin bon, on s'en fout.
un engin de chantiers non parce qu'après
les mecs sur Fingeriew vont dire oui
vous avez dit une pteuse mais c'est pas
une
pteuseitude et ce qui est normal
et ce qui est normal l'intelligence
collective au service
collaborative
euh donc tout ça euh ouais alors la
question était est-ce que je vais être
castor parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle ceux qui font barrage. Moi je me
suis jamais senti castor même si de fait
bien sûr j'ai voté Macron. Euh je sais
pas. La réponse est je ne sais pas. Je
sais déjà pas pour qui je vais voter au
premier tour. Tu imagines bien que je
sais pas pour qui je vais voter au 2è.
Je pense pour l'instant que quoi qu'il
en soit, je voterai.
Ouais des phrases comme ça.
Quand il y a il y a un journal français
qui dit euh qui titre euh
beaucoup d'é lecteurs de gauche vont
Ouais. l'idée. Ouais. Ouais.
Bah c'est c'est compréhensible. Alors il
titre parce que évidemment il faut un
titre un peu accrocheur mais l'article
était intéressant puisque oui ça parle
des bah de exactement ce dont on vient
de parler que à quoi bon voter Macron
contre Le Pen si c'est pour se retrouver
avec des flics qui mettent des coups de
couteau dans les tentes qu'on accueille
2 degrés dehors
alors qu'il fait de degrés dehors. Enfin
bon oui oui oui c'est pire on a atteint
des sommets de d'ignominique quoi. C'est
c'est incroyable donc je comprends tout
à fait. Oui oui oui. Bon, je serai pas
de toute façon moi j'ai jamais été très
prosélite hein. Comme je te dis, je
donne mon avis après on est d'accord
avec moi, on n pas d'accord, on débat,
on discute, on boit un coup. Ça, j'ai
aucun souci avec ça. Mais j'ai jamais
trop, j'avance pas en disant "J'ai
raison, suivez-moi. Je me sens pas l'âme
ni d'un influenceur comme je disais tout
à l'heure." Désolé, mais je crois que je
sais pas ce qu'on fout là. En gros, elle
dit il aurait fallu des journalistes ou
un journaliste la contradiction
pour apporter la contradiction. Donc
même elle reconnaît que bon un peu trop
tard en joy que le dispositif est est
est fait pour faire de la communication
à bas à bas coup. Bah ça revient ce
qu'on disait sur le la guerre des
réseaux sociaux et du numérique
là-dessus. Ouais, la campagne va se
faire bah en plus il y a le coronavirus
qui peuvent pas faire de meeting que
c'est compliqué d'aller les tracter sur
les marchés d'aller au contact. Là ça va
être ça va être la guerre
là. Ça va vraiment jouer sur les réseaux
sociaux.
Bah ouais ouais.
Il ils son ils sont dans la merde quand
même non ?
Qui il
Bah ceux qui veulent récupérer le
pouvoir.
Ouais ceux qui y sont dans la merde
aussi hein puisque on le rappelle c'est
la structure qui est merdique.
Est-ce qu'il y a un entrisme sur France
interne
de la part de qui ?
La question c'est Guillaume Meris chez
France inter. C'est un piège aussi
l'entrisme.
L'entrisme, c'est-à-dire
je te lis la question.
Bah préciser et faites des efforts aussi
hein.
Je te je te repose une autre question
qu'on t'a déjà posé en départ. Comment
s'informe-t-il ?
Euh
ben moi, comme je fais du commentaire
d'actu, je m'informe en regardant les
infos générales
euh les la presse mainstream qui va du
Parisien à Libé.
Ça m'arrive de lire Valeurs actuelles.
Valeurs actuelles. Il t'aime beaucoup he
franchement. Oui, il m'aime bien. Il
m'aime bien.
Il t'aime bien. Il m'aime bien.
Ils ont fait plein de papiers sur toi.
Ouais. Il y a même une fois, j'avais
fait une cagnotte justement pour SOS
Méditerranée et ils avaient titré un
truc genre G fait une cagnotte pour SOS
Méditerranée et j'ai lu l'article et en
fait il disait juste que je faisais une
cagnotte pour SOS Méditerranée.
C'est sympa.
Et en fait c'était sympa. Don je l'avais
retweeté je crois. J'avais dit ben
merci. Tu sentais qu'ils étaient
vénères, mais bon, il y avait pas plus
de d'arguments que ça quoi. Euh donc
j'ai Ouais, ouais, j'essaie de lire. Moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est les les
arguments et puis ce que je vais choper
dans la rue. Donc ce que je vais choper
dans la rue, c'est ce qu'il y a dans les
médias. Donc ça ouais, ça m'arrive de
regarder ces news. Ça m'arrive de
Alors, tu regardes c'est quelle heure
tout seul la nuit, comment ça se passe ?
Oh non, il y a pas là. C'est très
chaotique quand je peux dans le métro.
Ouais, du replay. Ouais ouais, j'ai pas
la télé donc je regarde c'est devenu con
aujourd'hui de dire j'ai pas la télé
parce que tout est sur internet. Donc je
regarde. Ouais, je regarde quand je vois
un bah par exemple la dernière fois
Mélenchon, je me suis dit tiens allez
vas-y je vais regarder.
Donc j'essaie de de de d'anticiper ce
que je vais entendre. Donc j'essaie
d'avoir le plus de
d'opinions possibles qui me tombent dans
l'oreille avant de rencontrer ça sur le
terrain.
Question internet. Que pensent-t-il du
mouvement souverainiste ?
Euh ça me ça me fout le seum. C'est Non
non c'est je trouve ça très des
de se vouloir se
c'est en train de revenir très
fortement.
Je sais. Ouais ouais mais ouais parce
que quand il y a quand il y a la peur
qui revient ben tout le monde se replie
sur soi-même. Alors c'est compliqué là
d'avoir un débat sur le souverainisme
parce que il faudrait quelqu'un en face
qui avance des arguments et qu'on puisse
en débattre parce que là évidemment en
en parlant moi qui trouve ça triste, je
vais être très réducteur. Ça c'est sûr
et certain. Mais de toute façon, le
multiculturalisme est là. Elle est là
depuis toujours.
Donc je vois pas bien de qui on va se
protéger en étant souverainiste et en
arrêtant des décisions qui impactent la
totalité de l'humanité à une frontière,
à un m près d'un trait imaginaire. il
peut se passer ça ou ça. Enfin, je
trouve ça déjà
vraiment absurde. J'avais un débat sur
un débat pareil, un mec sur internet qui
avait pas aimé une de mes chroniques et
on débattait du multiculturalisme. Dit
mais de toute façon, on on est on on vit
dans le multiculturalisme mais depuis
euh depuis qu'on vit enfin les matières
premières voyagent, les marchandises
voyagent. Là, tu es en train de de
m'écrire avec un un ordinateur qui est
fait je sais pas où bout de la planète
conçu par
Ouais. Voilà, le logiciel c'est un mec
aux États-Unis. Donc, on vit là-dedans.
Donc, déjà le multiculturalisme, tes
fringues, tout ça, ce que tu bouffes, tu
vas manger de la pizza, tu vas manger
des sushis. Enfin, tu vis là-dedans. La
musique que tu écoutes, c'est pas la
musique du mec en bas de chez toi. Donc,
c'est pareil. Tu vis là-dedans au dans
ton territoire que tu appelles la France
et dont tu es très fier, tu as mis le
petit drapeau. Ben, il y a des
différentes cultures qui cohabitent, les
Bretons, les Basques.
Toi, toi, tu es de quelle région ?
Moi, je suis né en Bourgogne à côté de
Dijon et j'ai grandi en Franchecté.
Et donc au sein même d'un
Besançon. Besanton. Besançon.
Euh, ouais, Franche Compté c'est
Besançon. Moi j'habitais dans un tout
petit pâelin qui s'appelle Jé à côté de
Voule. 30 bandes de VZou.
C'est c'est loin de Mout.
Pas très loin. Non, c'est Mout c'est
dans le Juras, je crois, il me semble.
Ouais. Ouais. Ville la plus froide de
France.
Est-ce que tu verrais un appel d'un imam
à Mouth ?
C'est juste pour la littération. Bobby
la pointe. L'appel d'un imam à mouth.
Ouais. OK. OK. Je garde. Non non non, on
peut Alors là on applaudit pas parce
qu'il se trouve que bon, on est
impressionné déjà par cette saill.
Bon ben, je t'engage comme chroniqueur
sur ma prochaine émission si j'ai une
émission un jour.
Allô ? Alors oui ou non ?
Quoi ?
Tu verrais ça ?
Moi avoir une émission ?
Non. Avoir un appel d'imam à Mout ?
Ah c'est une vraie question en plus. Bah
oui pourquoi pas ? On s'en fout. Ah non
mais c'est chiant parce que ça réveille.
Il y en a des tôt le matin là. Non non
pour des raisons de grâce matinée. Criez
pas dans les rues. Faites la prière
tout. Faites bien ce que vous voulez
mais pas criez pas dans les rues.
Ça ça va devenir problématique ou pas ce
besoin en fait de s'affirmer dans son
culte ? Ça deviendra pas problématique
si tu pousses pas les gens dans leur
retranchement et si tu les exclus pas
advitam et ternam d'une société
en en justement en les forçant à se
retrouver entre eux parce que c'est là
où ils trouvent leur moyens de de
s'émanciper et de et de vivre sans se
faire emmerder. Enfin, je crois on a
tous les mêmes aspirations. Qu'on soit
croyant, pas croyant, qu'on croit en
tout et n'importe quoi, c'est d'être
peinard, de se sentir libre, de partager
des bons moments avec des amis. Enfin,
c'est pas très compliqué un être humain
quand même.
Mais si d'un coup on te dit "Bah non,
toi tu es exclu euh tu rentres pas dans
notre dans notre teuf et qu'à côté tu as
une teuf euh on dit "Ouais bah viens,
viens viens on va te on va te retourner
le cerveau." Bah tu vas te sentir plus
en sécurité dans cette fin. On te dit
pas d'ailleurs, je reprends. On te dit
pas tu vas te viens viens on a fait on a
fait les bonnes les bonnes choses à
bouffer et puis on te retourne le
cerveau à ton insu.
Si si tu as ce qu'on appelle la
République devrait tolérer et accepter
tout le monde et ça devrait plus être un
une espèce de club privé comme c'est en
train de devenir. Tous ceux qui se
revendiquent des valeurs de la
République, bah moi je veux bien, faut
d'abord me dire lesquels, mais je veux
bien la laïcité par exemple qui a un mot
hyper galvodé. Enfin, je dire la laïcité
c'est euh moi je suis até pratiquant
quoi. Euh non mais c'est vrai, tu vois,
je me dis bah non, il y a pas Dieu, ça
existe pas. Je vais avoir des croyants
leur disant "Mais non, Dieu ça existe
pas, je suis prosélite." Un ami
imaginaire parce que tu es un ami
imaginaire.
Non. Voilà. Ouais. Mais mais je m'en
fous que la personne à côté de moi, elle
croit
en Dieu en fait du moment qu'elle essaie
pas de m'imposer. Enfin, c'est toujours
pareil. Donc c'est les débats sur la
licité, c'est pénible.
Juste, j'en profite pour passer un
message personnel.
Tous ceux sur le forum qui ne posent pas
des questions et qui font simplement des
commentaires, je vais m'occuper
personnellement de vous de vous faire
bouger d'ici.
Ça c'est tu sais quand tu fais des
questions réponses dans les salles et tu
viens de faire voilà un petit un petit
truc comme ça puis est-ce qu'il y a des
questions dans la salle ? Il y a
toujours des gens qui disent "Alors moi
j'ai une question mais d'abord je
voudrais faire une remarque.
Non, on te Non et souvent c'est long et
après souvent il y a pas de questions en
vrai.
C'est juste une remarque.
Ton bouquin
euh ça fait voyager au 16e siècle d'un
petit gars qui se fait tabasser un peu
comme Jacouille mais en mode un peu un
peu gore
un peu vénère. Ouais. Euh euh pourquoi
ça ça t'a pris d'écrire comme ça sur sur
cette souffrance d'un d'un petit
handicapé et qui prend conscience qu'il
a un réel pouvoir ?
Euh ce qui m'ad, il y avait deux choses
qui m'intéressaient beaucoup, c'était
euh le positionnement d'un bouffon de
cours dans ce qu'on appelait tout à
l'heure la structure du pouvoir qui
ressemble un peu à la nôtre quand on
fait des chroniques dans la matinale
devant des politiques qui est un peu
titillé mais au final être intégré à la
structure. Donc il y a cette ambivalence
là, cette zone grise, ça m'intéressait
vachement de de la questionner.
D'ailleurs, dans le bouquin, il y a
beaucoup de questions parce que
Triboulet, donc le personnage se pose
beaucoup de questions, c'est un peu les
miennes quoi. Et la deuxième euh deuxème
la deuxième chose qui m'intéressait,
c'était les limites. Euh puisque la
fameuse question qu'on pose tout le
temps, tu me l'as pas posé encore,
merci. Non, peut-on rire de tout ? Elle
a toujours existé cette question et la
réponse est évidemment non et
j'ajouterai tant mieux.
Pourquoi pas rire de tout ?
Bah ça
peut pas rire de tout avec tout le
monde. Non. Ça y est, on est dedans.
[__] je voulais l'éviter. Non, mais
il y a des limites en France, moi qui me
vont très bien, celle de la loi, par
exemple, la diffamation, l'injure
public, même dans voilà, c'est c'est
dans une chronique humoristique ça, je
trouve ça bien que ça avait pas sa
place. Voilà, donc ça c'est une limite
mais c'est pas grave. Les limites, toute
liberté paradoxalement
est contrainte dans une limite. Voilà,
ça c'est le groupe paradoxe des des
philosophes depuis la nuit des temps.
C'est que voilà, il faut un cadre pour
que cette libertélà puisse s'exprimer.
C'est comme ça. Euh donc ça ça voilà ça
m'intéressait. La limite de Triboulet
était ne pas se moquer des femmes du
roi, donc ni de la reine, ni des
maîtresses, ni de la favorite. Donc ça
l'amuse évidemment de de titiller cette
cette zone là. Et puis je ne spoile pas
mais c'était ces deux chosesl qui
m'intéressaient. Le rôle du bouffon et
les limites. Est-ce que tu as appris à
écrire comme ça ?
Bah alors ça c'est gentil. Je je sais
pas. en lisant,
non, je sais je bah après, j'ai des
parents là, ils sont à la retraite mais
ils étaient libraires marchands de
journaux donc euh j'ai grandi là-dedans.
Alors euh non mais c'est pas compliqué
en vrai. Enfin je sais pas, je veux pas
faire le faux modeste mais il faut faut
écrire des trucs qui qui que tu auras
envie de lire. Tu écris des trucs que tu
auras envie de lire. Moi ce bouquin là
en le relisant, je me suis dit bon bah
ouais
je passe un bon moment. Non mais c'est
vrai, c'est aussi bête que ça. Mais même
mes chroniques, je fais ça, j'écris des
chroniques,
je fais des trucs qui me plaisent et
puis après je les partage. Et puis il y
a des gens il disent c'est de la merde.
Il y a des gens qui disent c'est génial.
Il y a des gens qui s'en foutent en
majorité. Faut bien quand même être
conscient et lucide et et puis tout va
bien quoi.
Est-ce que tu as trois rêves que tu as
pas encore exaucé ?
Ah, c'est marrant ça. Ah, j'ai jamais
pensé.
Oh, des trucs un peu Ouais, j'aimerais
bien faire du kayak avec des orcs.
Enfin, pas des orcs sur les kayaks. Non,
ça ça me ferait bien kiffer. J'adore les
orcs. Alors ça, voilà, je lance un
appel. Oui, j'habite à Terneu. Voilà.
Euh ouais, ça c'est bah ouais, ça ça
peut être un rêve. Ça peut être
considéré comme un rêve. Ça fait un
bilan carbone dégueulasse mais bon,
qu'est-ce que tu veux ? Je suis
végétarien donc bon. Euh, qu'est-ce que
pourrait y avoir d'autre ?
des choses personnelles, hein, tu veux
dire, parce que sinon je te dirai la 6e
République et il a démission de
Darmanin. Mais bon,
dream
euh Non, sinon non vraiment, ça fait
vraiment le mec est monomaniaque sur les
orcs. Mais non, sinon je je suis pas je
suis pas
déjà je suis pas très très ambitieux
et j'ai pas j'ai pas d'autres voilà, je
je
l'impression de me contenter de trucs
simples, ce qui une force et une chance
aussi quand même. J'ai pas besoin de
vivre dans un
pourquoi qu' en kayak pourquoi pas ?
Non, je sais pas parce que bon bah déjà
parce que l'eau elle est froide et j'ai
pas envie de me ciller le cul dans l'eau
et que j'ai pas envie de les déranger
non plus trop, je me dis le kayak c'est
le bon le bon juste milieu entre être à
côté ça doit être hyper impressionnant
le il y a pas de bruit tu vois c'est pas
un bateau à moteur je sais pas je
m'imagine bien comme ça au fil de l'eau.
Je suis parin d'une assos qui s'appelle
7 qui milite pour la fermeture des
delfinhinarium. Donc ça prend bonne voie
en France mais bon ça règle pas tous les
problèmes parce que les
dauphins seront pas remis dans des
sanctuairire il y en a qui vont être
vendus enfin il y a ça pose d'autres
problèmes mais en tout cas c'est en
bonne voie de de fermeture. Donc la
sauce s'appelle 7 AC et c'est pas moi
qui a trouvé le jeu de mot. Merci
beaucoup.
Et ça se trouve où
l'association le siège social tu veux
dire j'en sais à Nant je crois j'en sais
rien du tout.
Question : quelles sont pour lui les
meilleures conditions les bases pour un
bon débat ? Qu'est-ce qui fait un bon
débat ? Ah, il y a un truc que j'ai
découvert, bah je crois que c'est euh
euh Richard mon voisin dont je te
parlais tout à l'heure, ils organisaient
alors je sais pas si c'est lui qui a
créé le le système mais je t'explique.
Ça s'appelait les disputations. Donc tu
avais deux personnes qui débattaient, il
y avait quatre arbitres, il y en avait
deux qui jugaient la le facting de base
quoi. Si on dit : "Il y a 60 %, enfin un
mec qui disait non, je viens de
vérifier, c'est 12." OK, basique, donc
tu deux comme ça et deux autres arbitres
qui jugeait les biais de raisonnement.
Donc tout ce qui est appel à la
popularité par exemple genre oui mais
tout le monde pense que donc ils avaient
les sifflets donc c'est une expérience
en fait he c'est ce serait compliqué de
je sais pas en fait ça serait compliqué
mais en tout cas c'est assez marrant à
regarder donc c'est une joute comme ça
ils ont chacun la parole ils ont je tête
mais il devait avoir 20 minutes chacun
puis après 10 minutes puis après voilà
et c'est assez intéressant parce que ça
t'oblige à être rigoureux dans ta dans
ton argumentation
et ça te squeiz tous les trucs de filou
quoi. De toute façon, il y a deux
bouquins à lire si tu veux regarder un
débat à la télé entre les politique.
C'est l'art d'avoir toujours raison de
Chopenhower et le prince de
de le prince de de Macavel quoi. Une
fois que tu as une fois que tu as lu ces
deux bouquins, tu regardes un débat et
tu fais bon bah ça c'est page 12, ça
c'est et ça devient un spectacle. Ça
devient plus un c'est plus un débat
d'idée. C'est à qui va bouffer l'autre,
à qui va gagner. C'est un
prendre le contrôle de la dialectique.
Ouais, c'est un combat de catch. Donc
bon.
Donc ça ça peut être intéressant si on
aime le catch mais ça a pas tellement
d'intérêt démocratique. Donc les
conditions d'un
bon débat, je saurais pas répondre
précisément mais là il y a une piste, je
trouve avec ces ces fameuses
disputations et j'aimerais bien que je
sais qu'à une époque ils avaient relancé
un peu le truc et ça serait intéressant
qu'il y a des politiques qui se
confrontent à ça. J'aimerais bien les
voir dans ce dans cette configuration
parce que tu sais, il y a des arbitres,
vous avez mis des chaises de d'arbitre
de tennis, il sifflent à chaque fois
qu'il y a un truc, il y a un côté un peu
spectacle mais au service de du ouais
d'un débat d'idée éclairé quoi, on va
dire.
Question internet, s'est-il déjà fait
violenter en tentant une interview ?
Euh non, non, non, en violonté, non,
physiquement non. Euh, j'avais fait une
manif pour tous, une des premières
manifes pour tous que j'avais faites et
il y a un mec qui m'a interrompu dans
l'interview que je faisais de quelqu'un
en disant "Tu es payé combien pour faire
ta [__] à France Interre ?" Et en mode
"Ouais, je je fais le ququé quoi." Et
donc je lui ais répondu 200,
il avait répondu "Ah ouais, c'est tout."
Donc déjà, j'avais diffusé le son parce
qu'il était rigolo et après j'avais dit
bah bouge pas, je vais je finis
l'interview parce que ce que tu as fait
c'est pas hyper poli he pour la personne
que j'interview c'est pas pas top et
après je viens t'interviewer et après
j'avais été donc je pense c un peu la
mouvance identitaire c'était pas les
skins violents mais c'était un peu voilà
il cétait un peu chaud et tout entre mec
tu penses de la dissolution de général
non mais en vrai je finis c'était
intéressant parce que j'ai été vraiment
les voir pas en mode provoque mais en
mode bah allons-y quoi.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de la
dissolution de génération identitaire ?
Ça c'est compliqué. Je sais pas quelle
porte ça ouvre quoi.
J'ai pas envie enfin j'ai pas envie de
m'en satisfaire parce que j'aurais envie
de me satisfaire que ces gens n'existent
pas.
Euh ça ouvre une porte sur Oui,
effectivement si tu commences à
dissoudre des groupes avec lesquels tu
es pas d'accord, bah ça va ça ça c'est
on sent on sent la pente glissante quoi.
On sent aussi le calcul politique pardon
je postne beaucoup. On sent le calcul
politique de
donner des gages de
non on n'est pas d'extrême droite, vous
avez vu ça ça va servir pendant la
campagne. La manœuvre politique est
grossière à mes à Bile quoi. Je pense
que ça ça fonctionnera.
Après, j'avais vu passer un truc très
marrant, tu vois, ils postent des
photos, donc ils font des opérations
avec des doudounes et des hélicos.
Enfin, en plus, ils ont du pognon. Et il
y avait une photo à un moment donné, je
crois qu'il dans les Alpes où tu voyais
un réfugié et puis je sais pas, je un
mec en doudoune qui lui montrait genre
la sortie, tu vois. Et tu imagines que
le gars, il vient de se taper à travers
ses 12 pays planqués dans des camions à
travers à la nage des machins, il avait
plus de pied et tout. Et tu imagines que
le gars il va faire "Ah bon ben je
rentre c'est débile quoi. C'est c'est
une espèce de Ouais. de propagande de
com." Alors il y a je retiens un truc si
on veut être tout à fait taquin, c'est
que leur slogan c'est des fond de
Europe. Donc ils sont plus tellement
souverainistes. Maintenant ils pensent
au niveau européen et c'est un progrès.
C'est bien.
Après on va peut-être défendre le monde
hein.
Bah voilà, on y vient, tu vois petit à
petit.
Question internet de euh 16 chevaux.
Comment
déjà les jeux de mots ? C'est non.
Vas-y.
Comment aimerait-il mourir ? Un mout
quand même. Et c'était un
moutormant.
Dans ton lit en dormant ?
Bah ouais ouais. Si je veux être
honnête, c'est ça le Ouais. Ah j'ai pas
l'âme d'un martyre hein. Je je veux pas
te dire sur
Est-ce que tu pourrais faire un débat
avec Pascal pro ?
Non parce que ça serait pas intéressant.
Enfin, je je corrige un peu ce que je
veux dire. Je ferai pas un débat
télévisé ou médiatique ou même ici avec
Pascal prou. Je ferai pas un débat s'il
y a un tiers, si il s'agit de faire le
show pour la caméra ou ou un micro. Par
contre, aller boire un café avec lui et
lui dire Pascal comment ça se passe ?
Volontiers, pas de problème.
Que penses-t-il de Francis Lalane ?
Pourquoi tu rigoles ? Bah Francisque
parce que c'est Francis quoi. Bon euh
émouvant, c'est je l'ai rencontré, j'ai
fait une chronique avec lui. Il est
émouvant parce qu'il est totalement
sincère. Il est vraiment sincère, il est
à fond dans son truc. Euh faut l'inviter
ici. Tu vas voir, il va te retourner le
truc. Par contre, il faisait des
concerts de 7h. Donc euh prévois de la
il risque de partir de post.
Question question d'internet. Le bouffon
du roi ne désamorce-t-il pas l'esprit de
révolte ?
Alors voilà, c'est tout le sujet.
Merci. l'exutoire qui permet digérer les
injustices mais sans lutter contre.
Exactement. À quel moment ? C'est toute
la question la problématique du livre. À
quel moment tu es la caution du pouvoir
? À quel moment ? Parce que tu as beau
faire le rebelle comme on fait nous à la
radio ou comme le faisait le bouffon du
roi à dire tes vérités à qui tu veux à
des gens puissants ou en tout cas
prétendument puissant tu n'en restes pas
moins un rouage de cette de ce pouvoirlà
en étant voilà à une heure de grande
écoute dans un système médiatique
important
donc oui oui c'est c'est exactement la
problématique du livre donc évidemment
j'ai pas de question moi je alors moi en
tant qu'humoriste, je peux répondre en
tant que que personne qui pratique, je
me dis que
égoïst je suis je suis mieux là, je
saurais pas quoi faire d'autre en vrai.
Donc là, j'en viens à la prochaine
question. Question d'un jeune 4
dynamique. Guillaume,
où et comment tu te vois dans 10 ans ?
Alors, c'est impossible de J'en sais
rien du tout. Non, je me projette pas en
plus. Non, non, je suis nul là-dessus.
Aucune idée et tant mieux d'ailleurs.
Quel média rejoindrais-tu après interne
si tu avais le choix ?
J'en créerai un je pense
avec Pierre Emmanuel.
Ouais, pourquoi pas ? Carrément très
bonne idée.
On lui passe le bonjour.
Ouais, évidemment. Ouais.
Alors, il y a il y a il y a des fans de
Dieu donné qui ont débarqué.
Ah !
Que pensent-il de Dieu donné ?
Oh là là, ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas
entendu. Je sais pas. Je
Est-ce que tu devrais prendre un café en
public avec lui ?
Non.
Bah, quel intérêt en fait ? Non, non,
non. B non. Euh c'est bah pareil, je
crois qu'on avait déjà parlé la dernière
fois mais euh ouais, c'est du gâi dieu
doné parce que en tant qu'humoriste,
nous quand on a commencé, enfin ma
génération quoi, euh c'était le c'était
l'idole quoi. Parce que on l'a dit 15000
fois mais mec super fort en écriture,
super comédien. Euh bah voilà, tout le
monde est d'accord là-dessus. Le divorce
de Patrick, ça reste un des à mon avis
un des meilleurs solen scènes
humoristiques que j'ai vu, hein, c'est
sûr et certain. Et puis après bah tout
ce qu'on sait la provoque d'abord et
puis après on se dit "Bah attends,
c'était un personnage ou c'était au
premier degré ce que tu as dit ?" Après
des interviews euh où on voit bien que
c'est au premier degré, un un compagnon
avec Alain Soral, patati patata patati
patata.
Que pens-t-il du tirage au sort des
citoyens ?
Ouais. Alors
euh pour faire quoi ? Il y a des fois je
suis pour et des fois je suis contre.
Euh je m'explique, je suis contre dans
la justice, je suis contre les jurés
d'assise. Moi, je serais tiré au sort,
ça me ferait chier. Je crois qu'il faut
payer une amende pour pas y aller. Ou
alors, je ferai comme les anciens au
services, je ferai le teb parce que je
me sens pas moi. Non, mais tu vois, je
crois que tu peux être évoqué si tu
arrives et que tu fais Je pense que
voilà. Euh parce que je me sens pas moi
en tant que citoyen de juger
l'avenir d'un d'un être humain. Je
voilà, ça me va pas. Euh
tu délègues ?
Ouais. Ouais. et je délègue à des
professionnels de justice. Ça me pose
pas de problème. Ouais, vraiment, je
préfère.
Mais dans le dans les décisions
politiques, je serai assez pour
et là ça va ressembler à un programme
politique réforme des institutions. Je
serai pour garder l'Assemblée nationale
telle qu'elle est en y ajoutant de la
proportionnelle
parce que on peut pour l'instant elle
est plus représentative mais on peut
faire en sorte qu'elle le soit plus. Il
y a des outils qui existent pour qu'elle
le soit plus. On la garde telle qu'elle
est. Le Sénat citoyen tiré au sort sur
la base du volontariat, pouvoir de
contrôle et de proposition.
Et je mettrai dans le game ce que
Macron, il a essayé de faire mais
évidemment en bananant complètement le
Conseil économique et social euh d'en
faire un un outil de de d'expert.
Ben je sais pas, tu fais une réforme de
l'agriculture, ben voilà, tu réunis tous
les gens, y compris des lobbyistes, mais
affichés comme lobbyistes, des des
responsables associatifs et tu les fais
dialoguer. Pareil, pouvoir de contrôle,
pouvoir de proposition. Quand je dis
Macron, il a banané parce que c'est ce
qu'il a fait avec les 150 citoyens tirés
au sort et là c'est encore une fois
foutage de gueule total mais ouvert
quoi. C'estàdire qu'il dit non non on
prendra tout. OK, je prends trois jokers
et là le gars il prend plus rien du
tout. Enfin
je trouve les gens extrêmement patients
parce que tu
patients ou résigné
je les trouve pas résigné. Non, j'en ai
rencontré quelques-uns la la convention
citoyenne. Ils sont dégoûtés, ils sont
pas résignés. Ils se disent "Putain,
mais on a investi du temps et tout, on a
des famille, on a des boulots." Enfin,
c'est les c'est pas leur taf de faire ça
quoi. Et je les sens pas résignés. Ils
ont pas laissé tomber. Je c je crois je
suis d'accord qu'il faut combattre la
résignation
mais
je suis assez optimiste sur la nature
humaine. Il y a toujours une il y a
toujours une petite étincelle. Il y a
toujours une petite flamme. Si elle est
petite, faut la rallumer. Mais mais je
suis assez optimiste là-dessus. Donc
voilà mes propositions pour la
réforme institutionnelle.
Question internet.
Ça aurait de la gueule. Non en plus
c'est pardon ou symboliquement le Sénat
c'est intéressant d'avoir comme je sais
pas si tu es déjà allé mais
c'est vraiment les ors de la République
hein. Truc c'est vraiment de la dorure
des sièges et demi.
Oh là là. Ouais. Et alors ça serait
intéressant de mettre bah non voilà une
assemblée populaire qui arrive. Ouais.
Je ferai ça moi.
Question internet. Dans quel homme
politique aimerait-il se réincarner ?
Euh
Alexandre le Grand, j'en sais rien. Tu
sais un mec qui pèse pour pouvoir dire à
un moment mais à un moment de l'histoire
où tu as vraiment tout le tout le
pouvoir sur tout le continent et tu peux
dire stop, on va arrêter de se [__]
sur la gueule maintenant c'est la
démocratie et ce sera comme ça. Non plus
sérieusement
j'en sais rien.
un grec là qui plaidait sur le la gora
là chose comme ça un truc un peu de la
gueule quoi.
Tu aimes les films de gladi ?
Ouais. Tu aimes les films de gladiateur
?
Je vais te lire je vais te lire un
commentaire que qui me tombe sous l'œil
là et je vais te demander d'y répondre.
C'est c'est un commentaire qui est
méchant.
Ah bah vas-y. B J'aime bien.
Euh air interpilote de points. Bobo
gauchot pas très drôle avec des
avant-bras maigrichon rien de bon à
attendre.
Alors avant-bras maigrichon là on est
sur quelque chose de factuel je peux pas
mentir. Oui he il y a pas tellement de
d'épaisseur. Je fais les efforts. Mais
moi je fais les efforts plôt au niveau
du du gain.
C'est vrai que tu as perdu un peu, hein.
Ouais. Bon alors ça euh un point pour
lui euh au début il y avait Bobo
Bobo gauch pas très drôelot
alors pas très drôle ça c'est
c'est pas très drôelot attention il a
pas très drôle OK on est sur quelqu'un
qui a travaillé pas très drôle ouais ça
je l'accepte tout à fait enfin c'est
évident que que il y a des gens qui me
trouvent pas drôl des fois ça m'amuse je
réponds je dis bah ouais mais bon les
gens il il y a des gens qui me trouvent
drôle quoi. Je fais qu'est-ce qu'il me
conseillerait de faire ? Faut que je
démissionne ? Qu'est-ce que je dois
faire ? Ouais je sais pas. Peut-être
qu'il faut que tu adoptes son point de
vue.
Oui, c'est ça. Ou je envoie-moi des
exemples de blagues, je les dirai à
l'antenne. Je je veux bien faire des
efforts. Je suis ouvert à la discussion.
Et puis Bobo Gauchot. Oui. Bah ça c'est
l'éternel truc. Oui. Oui. Oui. Oui. Bobo
gauchotud. Oui, si tu veux.
Alors, encore une question qui revient
souvent. Que penses-t-il de Jean-Marc
Jeancovici de Pablo Servigne ?
Euh Jeancovici, je connais assez peu
donc je pourrais pas tellement en dire
plus. Euh Pablo Servin, j'aime beaucoup
euh notamment euh un de mes livres
préférés qui est l'entraide de l'autre
loi de la jungle qui je trouvais un
bouquin essentiel, vraiment capital,
important parce que il il change
complètement le paradigme. Aujourd'hui,
on vit dans la dans un monde de
compétition
parce couvert par le darwinisme social
qui veut que c'est le plus fort qui
gagne. Donc c'est normal que la société
soit bâtie comme ça sur le règne des
winners et de ceux qui gagnent et qui
dominent, qui écrasent les autres. et
lui sort un bouquin en disant "Bah oui,
mais ça c'est un choix, c'est pas
naturel, c'est un choix qui a été fait
parce qu'en l'occurrence dans la nature,
si on veut se référer à la nature, c'est
plutôt la coopération qui gagne, y
compris la coopération entre les
espèces."
Donc ça me paraît vraiment nécessaire de
le lire. Là où j'ai un peu plus de mal
avec Pablo et les collapsologues, c'est
que je trouve que c'est un peu
démobilisateur la collapsologie
puisqu'ils disent "De toute façon, c'est
foutu euh on va tous crever, essayons de
crever le moins mal possible." Voà, ils
vont m'en vouloir parce que j'ai résumé
leur truc, ils vont dire "Espèce de
fumier, mais bon, le fumier, c'est du
compost quelque part." Non, voilà, c'est
je trouve que la collapsologie est un
peu quoi tuas dit quoi ?
Développement durable.
Développement durable, je trouve. Voilà,
à la collapsologie, à ce je trouve à ce
défaut là à mes yeux.
Alors, j'enchaîne sur la la question
juste après. C'est quoi le pire ? C'est
le découragement ou la résignation ?
Bah, la résignation, il y a un truc de
plus pérenne. On a l'impression que la
résignation, il y a il y a rien qui qui
pourra nous nous sortir de là. Le
découragement, ça ça a l'air d'être un
peu plus enfin ça sonne un peu plus
momentané. Mettre un coup de pied au cul
en disant "Allez, ça va aller."
Est-ce que tu as des conseils pour les
jeunes générations ? Avant, je vais te
demander trois livres.
Et ben l'entraide l'autre loi de la
jungle de Pablo Servigne, euh ben j'ai
envie de citer Philippe Bwix qui un ami
m'a conseillé et qu'après j'ai été voir
sur Finkerview, cette excellente chaîne
confusionniste. Euh non, qu'est-ce que
j'ai dit ?
Non. Donc j'ai lu euh alors c'est pas
son hit a priori mais j'ai lu le bonheur
était pour demain et ça m'a vraiment
bien plu puisque c'est une critique des
du la religion des nouvelles
technologies si je veux aller vite mais
pas sous un prisme vieux con c'était
mieux avant
retournons
à la bougie quoi. Et ça m'a ça m'a parut
hyper intéressant et le troisième c'est
le mien.
Ça c'est intér
le roi n'avait paris non tu m'as pas
donné tu m'as pas dit que c'était
interdit. Le roi nav Paris aux éditions
La Tess sortie le 17 mars.
Il est là. Voilà,
il est beau.
J'ai trouvé ça
déjà lisez-le parce enfin achetez-le
parce qu'il est beau.
J'ai trouvé ça très triste.
Sure. Mais tu as pas fini. Tu m'as dit
J'ai pas fini mais le début le début
Ah bah c'est c'est 16e siècle he c'est
pas Disneyland.
Disneyland c'est triste en vrai aussi.
Quand il se fait tabasser et que tu
décris ça tu es venu comme ça ? Tu as
écrit ça comment ? Le matin, le soir ?
J'ai pas de je j'aime pas les rituels
moi. Alors je déteste m'en imposer. Donc
tu aimes pas les rituels
? Je trouve ça contraignant et j'aime
pas cette contrainte là en tout cas me
plaît pas. Je suis pas genre j'écris 1h
à 2h du matin en mettant une bougie là
une photo de triboulet. Enfin je
critique pas les gens qui le font s'ils
ont besoin de ça. J'essaie de pas avoir
besoin parce que pour avancer comme à
l'époque où il y avait des tournées,
j'étais un peu toujours en vadrouille.
J'avais besoin d'écrire des fois dans le
train dans une gare entre voilà entre
deux trains. Donc j'écris un peu tout le
temps mais j'ai pas mal lu surtout pour
écrire celui-là parce que j'y
connaissais rien en histoire. J'étais
vraiment
Est-ce que tu sors ce vocabulaire, ce
champ lexiquel là ? Comment tu as fait
pour ? Ben
j'ai bossé mon petit.
Comment tu as fait pour l'approprier ?
Ben je voulais pas, c'était toute la
difficulté c'était je voulais pas que ça
sonne trop vieux et je voulais pas que
ça sonne trop moderne évidemment. Donc
je voulais j'ai éliminé tout de suite le
vieux français parce que bon bah c'est
imbitable quoi. Et puis euh et puis je
voulais quand même qu'il y ait des
petits marqueurs de cette époque-là de
notamment dans les dialogues. Donc bah
je me suis renseigné, j'ai bossé avec la
radio Pommono qui fait euh voilà qui est
éditrice chez ATS et qui fait l'émission
avec nous à France Interre qui a elle
écrit deux livres sur Alienord
d'Aquiten. qui qui avait une
bibliographie pas dégueu sur comment on
vivait au Moyen-Âge, qu'est-ce qu'on
bouffait, qu'est-ce qu'on portait comme
fringue, enfin la base quoi.
Comment se faisait insulter,
comment on se faisait insulter, quel
était le rapport à la mort, quel était
le rapport au rire, quel était euh bah
voilà tout ça quoi, rapport à à la
domination. Enfin, il y a j'ai j'ai
discuté avec des historiens, j'en
profite pour remercier Guillaume Berton
et Cédric Michon qui m'ont pas mal aidé.
Guillaume Berton, c'est un universitaire
qui est spécialiste de Jean Marot qui
n'a pas un très bon rôle dans mon livre.
C'est un peu mon interprétation à
travers triboulet de ce que pouvait être
un poète de cours. J'en ai fait un peu
un BHL, ce qui est pas hyper sympa pour
Jean Marot. Euh et puis Cédric Michon,
c'est un des spécialistes français de
François 1er. Et pareil comme François
1er a pas une super image dans mon
livre, en tout cas pas celle qu'on
apprend à l'école avec le le roi du haut
de sa superbe, la légende dorée quand
ils appellent ça, j'avais quand même
besoin d'aller voir un mec comme ça pour
lui dire "Bon voilà moi ce que
j'aimerais en faire." Et il m'a dit "Oui
oui. Non mais de toute façon déjà tu es
romancier, donc permets-toi ce que tu
veux. En plus c'est la vision de
Triboulet de François 1er, donc là tu es
tu es tranquille. et sur pas mal de
trucs, il m'a dit "Non, non, mais voilà,
il y a des trucs passionnants, mais on
m'aurait appris ça à l'école, ça je
voilà juste j'en raconte un comme ça tu
voilà euh la bataille de Pavis, François
1er se fait prendre faire prisonnier à
la bataille de Pavis." Alors que c'est
une bataille qui qu'ils avaient
quasiment gagné quoi. Les Français
avaient gagné contre l'Empire de de
Charlequin. Et d'un coup, comme c'est
quasiment gagné et que le kiff de
François 1, je résume je stanne perdre
mais le kiff de François 1er, c'est la
la chevalerie, il part tout seul devant.
Ouais, niquez-vous. C'était le
niquez-vous de l'époque quoi. Donc il
pète sa ligne de canon, c'est les débuts
de l'artillerie. Donc les mecs peuvent
plus tirer. Donc euh il y a un rapport
de force qui commence à s'équilibrer
très rapidement et il voit euh donc le
roi de France était quand même un des
mecs les plus puissants du monde à
l'époque se faire choper comme un bléot
par euh les adversaires quoi. Et ça tu
vois tu dis quand on quand on te dit
François 1 le chevalier Bayard et cetera
et cetera, tu tu as des images en tête.
En tout cas c'est chargé de de symbole
de prestige. Mais c'est excuse-moi mais
de faire ça c'est se comporter comme un
gland. Et il y a pas mal de choses comme
ça qui sont historiquement véridiques
quoi. Ça, je les ai pas inventé
évidemment.
Qu'on peut transposer au 21e siècle
carrément puisque les humains ont pas
tellement changé déjà il y a pas très
très longtemps.
Venez me chercher. Tu l'as pris comment
?
Ouais, venez me chercher. Bah c'est la
la l'arrogance ultime du gars qui sait
qu' qui risque rien quoi. C'est fou
quoi. Mais tu as pas dit ça depuis
combien de temps ? Au CM2 tu le disais
quoi. Venez me chercher. C'est on joue
pas à chat.
Non, tu vois le niveau de de confiance
et d'inconscience, j'allais dire qu'il
faut pour dire un truc pareil. En plus,
c'était à propos de l'affaire Benala
donc c'était vraiment bah à quoi tu vas
faire ? C'est vraiment qu'est-ce que tu
vas faire quoi
et mec ? Tu tu as de la chance que les
gens soient patients là
ou résignés.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Euh parce que je suis vieux, c'est ça.
J'ai Non, non mais OK.
Taille à la mer, quelque chose à la mer.
Euh bah vous résignez pas mais ça c'est
un peu bateau. Tentez tentez le coup,
tentez-le.
Sur un mal-entendu, ça ça peut marcher.
Vous êtes pas à l'abri euh d'être
heureux et de réussir des trucs.
Échouer,
j'avais peut-être déjà dit ça la
dernière fois. Échouer, c'est bien.
Guillum,
c'est mieux. Attends, j'ai une punchline
defin non, je sais pas. C'est mieux de
de d'échouer en tentant des choses. Ne
pas les tenter, c'est déjà échoué. C'est
pas de moi, je sais pas de qui c'est,
mais je le pense vraiment. Tout est
possible.
La partie n'est pas terminée. L'arbitre
n'a pas sifflé la fin. Macron n'a pas
gagné. Le système libéral n'a pas gagné.
On va y arriver collectivement. On va
penser collectivement les conditions
d'émancipation de chacun et de chacune.
Guillaume Meris, merci.
Merci à vous, à toi et à vous hein,
monsieur une équipe. Ah.
[Musique]